welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to the
pregame
[Applause]
do it for the men but it's like sexual
tension it's not relationship attention
so you can kind of do a cheat code you
can go get a BBL get a nice body and you
do get more attention from them than if
you're flat right but here's the thing
though no no but but listen though but
it goes so deeper though because I know
what you're talking about and she has a
great body yeah so you got to think
about how far down deep that she is
within watching the Instagram models
within watching The Cosmopolitan
magazines
doesn't look good to a man wait you
think that men have higher standards for
women not that the men have the higher
standards they have to live up to just
to clarify I think men have highest
under School women for women so like the
women have higher beauty standards to me
yes and that's what's making women feel
like they need to comply with these
standards who's pickier men or women men
women are more complacent than them
are more complacent yeah I think they
accept all them men do you think men are
very like if they're they've got a
certain standard they're more rigid than
women I think men are pickier than women
100 certainly but they will not marry it
they will not settle down with somebody
with a fake or lips the eyebrows and if
they do it ain't gonna last so I I done
an only fans but it wasn't like vagina
boobs it was lingerie yeah builds right
whatever I'd done it and when I finished
it I felt very degraded I felt very like
why did I actually do that now I know
there's girls out there who do that they
don't feel that way that is perfectly
fine you do you you feel the way you
feel but me personally like like in the
future how like when I have kids and all
in the future and if my kids found out
about that they'll probably get bullied
in school there are people like oh your
mom doing this your mom doing that and
your man as well he's not coming if you
don't respect yourself and you're
selling your body online I can't speak
for everyone I can just speak for myself
if you're selling your body online like
that there's not a there's not a high
respect for yourself
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
uh before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos
um a couple announcements before we
start the show I'm the first is that
guys all super chats are going to be
read today over uh what over what
blessing what are you gonna pick 20.
over twenty dollars I'm also blessing
what are we saving for what what piece
of equipment are you haggling me for now
we need
we need to come okay Kick Out camera
um saw the last show um we actually had
to file a police or this lady called the
cops in us because we kicked her out so
if you want to see that check out the
last stream which we're not going to
have today right right no no no no no no
no no no
yeah so I literally had to file um to go
talk to the cops in the middle of the
show it was actually really crazy
um but they were cool they were actually
fine so it's fine also guys we're gonna
look at um going up in shows one day a
week I don't know if it's gonna start
next week or the week after but we're
thinking about Tuesdays so we're gonna
go up from two shows a week to three
um also guys
um we have two clips channels just
pearly clips and pearl daily so make
sure you go subscribe to both and also
guys we have four membership tiers the
first tier is gonna let you be a part of
the chat tonight and how many likes to
open up the chat blessing
one thousand okay a thousand likes and
we open up the chat tonight second tier
is our behind the scenes Vlogs um you
can see me freestyle rap um I'm real I'm
really good I'm really good nobody
believes me but that's fine um the third
tier you get to connect with me on
social media um so that means you
basically have my inbox to ask me
different you know um questions about
YouTube whatever you're trying to grow
in and also guys fourth tier which is
the best tier is a one-on-one call with
me once a month I really recommend this
if you're trying to start a podcast or a
live show I can give you a lot of
insight
um though you're really not gonna get
unless you've done it um and save you a
lot of headache um that I went through
that you wouldn't have to also guys
follow my Instagram I took away my first
one
um just pearly things one is my second
one and also guys they've banned me five
times on Tick Tock can you believe it
five times wow I know I know it's like
you go for the whales one time and they
they come after you whatever uh my new
one is just pearly things for I have
another one that's just pearly things so
make sure you go follow both of those
and go follow our talent channels which
is um King Richie's and Auntie Jenny
make sure you go subscribe to both and
sign up for our Google form we're gonna
do some meetups here in London um we're
maybe even gonna do like a concert where
we have former guests come back and like
perform so I think it'll be pretty cool
um and yeah that's all of the
announcements I think before the show so
um welcome to the show guys
um thank you thank you we're gonna go
around everyone say your name your age
your relationship status and a fun fact
starting here and then go around
hey I'm Amina house I'm 33 years old and
I'm in a relationship 33 you look young
I totally thought you're like 25.
sometimes I say 32 because I take a year
off for Kobe
um go ahead
hi I'm story I'm in a relationship and
I'm 32 years old
[Laughter]
there's no one saying interesting facts
oh interesting facts
um I like traveling and learning
I do music I'm a music artist
okay Shaylee Ann I'm 34
um currently unavailable
interesting facts I'm kind of addicted
to toes
all right what's up guys my name is
Kadeem I'm 29 years uh interesting fact
sorry let me go back to relationship I'm
in a relationship
interesting Factor I'm a personal
trainer
we have a fully taken panel so that
doesn't happen often
usually single person
um okay today
um we're going to talk about how women
are really making Society completely
delusional and crazy and I really do
blame women for this okay um so my first
um my first thing that we're going to
talk about so we're just going to go
through something about the clown world
that we live in all right so I'm gonna
read this to you guys and I just want to
hear your thoughts um maybe the woman
was in the right I don't know you got
you guys can talk
let me like we can go through it
together as a class you know okay my
boyfriend's cancer battle was ruining my
mental health so I left him now I'm
running a marathon in his honor all
right awesome a woman running the London
Marathon for her ex-boyfriend has
admitted she left him because she
couldn't cope with his cancer battle
Danielle 32 was buying a house with gel
um friendson in London last year when he
was diagnosed with a rare form of brain
tumor at just 37. he needed a complex
operation radiotherapy and chemotherapy
and had to learn how to walk again while
all this was going on the physics
teacher Danielle began having panic
attacks in her mental health plummeted
so she ended the relationship she moved
to Thailand but remained friends with
him and is now running a marathon for a
brain tumor Charity she said she was
still figuring out her friendship with
him adding I felt like an awful person
leaving some somebody because they have
cancer but it was damaging my mental
health
um I'm gonna read the rest the couple
was buying a house together in Palmer's
green North London where gel who worked
as a Google software engineer began
vomiting and having dizzy spells after
numerous consultations with GPS and
ineffective treatments for an ear
infection and he began vomiting and
getting much worse he went to a private
MRI using his health insurance with
Google doctors found a grade for um I'm
gonna say this wrong grade four Mella do
blastoma tumor normally a cancer that
affects children he was booked for
surgery in September Danielle said we
are on a certain path
to a certain future within one day we
knew it wasn't going to work out like
that anymore I was so worried and
devastated I couldn't sleep or eat I was
having panic attacks and was on so much
medication to sort my out myself I just
couldn't function realizing they had to
split up she moved to Thailand with her
father but she stayed friends with gel
and kept up to date with his recovery
following his operation he had nerve
damage and paralyzed the right side of
his face leaving to a squint that causes
double vision he also can't fully close
his eyes and must use drop ointments eye
drops and ointments explaining her
decision to run the marathon in his name
for brain tumor research she's felt she
said I felt so helpless watching all the
sun float unfold
so I knew I had to do something like
like leave him question mark That's a
little bit deeper
um yeah so that's that's a lot yeah
that's a lot yeah so
I think from the headline that was
that's disgusting
um
they must have written that scare like
like they must have read it like that
scare reaction I think it's still quite
was it untrue
what was it what wasn't true I don't
know I guess you don't know the details
of her panic attacks and not eating that
those details just from reading that but
I don't understand how this made news
like that's somebody's personal
yeah she talked she talked to the News
That's what I'm saying that's weird like
why would you speak to the news about
how you're having panic
panic attacks maybe because your
ex-boyfriend had cancer
awareness awareness to the to the
maritime but what awareness though but
putting that aside it's it's not
something that I personally would do if
I was with someone that that was
terminally ill I would I would stay by
them I think it's a no-brainer I think
it's a if she was in his position what
would she like him to do
um maybe she didn't really love him from
the beginning as well but then you gotta
understand it must have been a lot for
her to do to take on yeah for sure
um you know she might have had to be
um catering to him or looking after him
24 7. it does take a toll on somebody
you know I mean as much as it's easier
to say I mean it's you know it's easy to
say I can't do it
but at the same time
it shows true love in my eyes that
you're able to support that some that
you know the somebody that you know that
you love
um at the lowest point of their life you
know I mean so for me it kind of shows
character in my opinion like if I was
going to stay yeah yeah like if I was if
I was the guy and I was going through it
I'd be thinking I'd want my loved ones I
want the people that that say that they
love me or it was there at my best time
to be there you know I you know the last
day of my life for I don't know like you
know life is short so you gotta look at
at every moment and Embrace Life as a
whole you can't look at the best moments
and think oh I love you because you know
we did this and we you was like this
with me but what happened when I'm Ill
you know you know when you get married
is sickness within sickness and health
Deputy was part you know what
you know I feel like that should play a
big part in in a lot of relationships
and even in like friendships if you love
somebody you love them to death
otherwise how can you love them you know
what I mean but that isn't taking my way
the stress that the other person would
have to go through to look after that
person don't you think it says a lack of
loyalty in society
what percent of women really would stick
around not many in this generation I
don't know do not think
I don't know women divorce their
husbands over like damn near nothing
because I lost their job empty Pockets
I didn't feel like myself anymore
um you've changed I needed to find
myself as my favorite one I'm like Diane
you have two children what about the
kids well I needed to find my what your
children this is the thing though yeah
go out with your boys but this is the
finger with Lavia you have to work with
love you gotta work with your partner
it's not something that you just think
oh okay like you know like like my
parents they were married for years and
I'm thinking I was just how did you stay
married they work together you go
through every single storm you you grow
through what you go through you know
what I'm saying that's love if you can
do it together that's the partnership
but I feel like you know in this
generation a lot of people don't see
they just see them they just seize the
moment they just you know what I'm
saying yeah they don't actually want the
real nitty-gritty they don't understand
they don't understand it takes to
actually maintain a relationship that's
what this generation I think men
understand it I think women don't some
men understand it some men some men
summon I wouldn't say oh man yeah
because if we look at the numbers the
women are the ones that are leaving
if the man didn't understand it true it
would be leaving the women are leaving
but is it because
of what did he do like a woman wouldn't
necessarily stay around if there's no
love there like I say for instance the
guy stays and he's just cheating just he
doesn't love his wife but he's just
there because he's there so he's going
out doing his thing is it because women
are like no I'm actually not putting up
with the disrespect
women shoot more than men nowadays I've
heard that I've heard the statistics are
pretty high when it comes to women and
really yeah what percent of men men can
get laid like what percent of men can't
you I think it's harder for girls
women have to control when it comes to
sex I mean for us we really have to be
out we're like you know what I I look at
as like um the Safari yeah where the
Predators yeah we've got to get our prey
but we've got to be strategic with it
yeah you've got to be like okay you know
you know what I mean so you have to be
very like smart with it and and at the
same time it's not easy whereas you know
no disrespect and you know
it's a lot easier
so that's what I mean where women have
been having trouble over like
sexual relations like you could go out
and pick a guy and nine times out of ten
you probably will
do you think that marriage is about love
or about Duty
ah I think it's a bit of both I was just
gonna say that I don't know I think
personally I think more love
love isn't for me isn't necessarily just
a feeling
love is multiple things
you know what I mean it's not it's not
that but you're not going to have
butterflies all the time you're not
going to be infatuated with that person
all the time it's like the same way that
you love your family they're probably
the most people that you have arguments
with that you can't stand most of the
time but you will like you love them
you're gonna ride for them like no
matter what they do you're always going
to be for the be there for you so which
one would you pick love or Duty more
your version of Love or Duty more
my version of Love okay it comes in with
that I think I think generally everybody
has their own definition
of love but individually everybody has
their own definition of love you know
what I mean and we can't we can't judge
when it comes to that I think marriage
is 100 Duty no love Duty really no yeah
I think it's about it's a duty it's
about commitment otherwise love is
relationship your book isn't commitment
love though I think that marriage is
commitment part love partially yeah I
would say yes but I think when it comes
down to it what's the difference between
a relationship and a marriage I would
say entirely
[Music]
it's almost like it's your role to show
your woman love the respect and you know
as a man you should be you know front
line and and make sure that you you
provide for your family and you know do
you know what I mean so I think it's a
bit of both yeah would you marry someone
that you didn't love no
would I marry someone I didn't love
I used to say I wanted an arranged
marriage honestly honestly oh my God
women picking the guys we love work out
for us not well
come on I think that is literally
because of how we think love should be
and compared to what it actually is
do you know okay so the first two or
three years obviously you're in the
honeymoon period and actually
um there's neurotransmitters like
chemicals in the brain that are
activated in that period and they do
wear off so like the in love lust
feeling does wear off and then obviously
it turns into a more attachment fondness
caring juicy probably and so you do have
to be committed to that type of Love
rather than always chasing that
honeymoon period otherwise yeah but this
is why this is why you're sorry but this
is why I say yeah like marriage and love
in general is work you can't expect the
butterflies they can't expect to be like
oh my God like you know I want to rip
her clothes off like you know you see
it's not like that let's be real you get
comfortable you get to that position
that's it in a situation where you are
like so used to each other that you
don't actually make enough effort for
each other and it's all about making
effort and making you know like a
routine
let's go every other week or let's book
this and you've got to make the effort
otherwise that like that spark that you
had the first time that would just you
know it will go off you need to light
that spark all the time and keep it lit
because you know what I'm saying like
a lot of people nowadays don't accept
that the person that you're with and
yourself is going to change and people
don't accept the change like I'm not the
same person I was a year ago
two years ago 10 years ago like I'm not
like in a relationship people always
refer back to oh you're not the same
person that I met well yeah and I'm glad
that I'm not because I'm human I'm
growing every day I learn new things
there's no way that I'm gonna stay the
same would you would you think so then
that's the thought on both parties
though because you guys supposed to be
growing together exactly yeah but then
you see that whole you see the the
the saying of all we grew apart is that
what you're trying to say I think women
just say that for a reason to leave yeah
you don't ever hear a man saying we grow
up
oh the Sparks people used to have
arranged marriages yeah they still do
some people still did and they worked
out better than women picking for
ourselves yeah but so so if it was about
love Sparks all that why isn't it
working
um the thing is at the time when
arranged marriages were more common you
also couldn't get divorced very easily
and things like that so we don't know I
think we should go back to that divorce
should be illegal
yo this is a chance
the husband's beating the wife see as
women we always go to the extreme why do
we gotta bring up the one percent
domestic violence relationships so did
did you did you press charges with the
police no of course not okay so how do I
know that's true
um
um how do I know it's true
because I'm saying that it happened yeah
but I don't get it no but I'm saying
because women always come on here and
they'll say that but it's like I don't
know if that's true because
for the fun of it why yeah um because
women lie all the time about abuse you I
don't know you personally I don't I hope
you're not but no I definitely wouldn't
no
and I I hear where you're coming from I
understand that there are women that put
men in very difficult situations which
is not right and I don't agree with and
you are absolutely right you don't know
me don't know me from Adam but I
definitely wouldn't come on here and say
that when it's not true well just I just
get confused like genuinely I don't
really understand when girls come on the
podcast but they didn't go to the police
like it doesn't compute to me because
it's like if you're if you're the
Loyalty it's the Loyalty side of things
for me I'm loyal to the Bone if you're
in something it's like and it also
depends on the type of person that
you're with and the situation and the
and yeah all that kind of stuff there's
so many different factors do people know
who you've dated like people know this
guy like who you've dated these guys
that did that yeah but so it's like
you're coming on here how is it loyal if
you're coming on here everyone knows who
they are there was like over 10 years
ago I would never mention names I would
never it was a point that I was trying
to prove in regards to marriage should
be
divorce should be um illegal and that
was just a point that I was bringing to
bring into the table yeah um I'll give
the abused girls out I'll give them an
out okay okay yeah that was the only
point I am very skeptical when women say
they were abused and they didn't go to
the police just in general
like they could be scared they could be
embarrassed there's so many different
factors and if you've not been through
it
well to me it's like if you're in two
different situations where you were
abused in both like my mind goes well
did you hit him first
that's true it's a pattern right
it's a
win in a relationship like that right
you know what you know well and that's
the thing like a lot of times like women
will say I was abused but like they're
hitting too you know so then that's just
an aggressive relationship that's very
true what I think about it
I want grandparents or great
grandparents or great great grandparents
I feel like they've been all through it
um yeah we hear about marriages over 20
some years 30 some years 40 some years
and they all have been through it so
what's our excuse when it comes to this
is what I'm saying you've got to grow
through what you go through and love is
work it's not something you just be like
Oh I'm gonna have this feeling for the
rest of my life you know it's work it's
not easy are you saying that they
weren't through domestic violence or
just I feel like it could be possible
but there's reasons why people say it's
because religion is because I don't
think that we understand love like they
do no it's just that's facts I mean I
believe that but that's why I think
divorce should be illegal okay now hear
me out because what's the point of
getting married that's true if you
believe in divorce it's true just be in
a relationship that's why men are
getting married that's just like we all
believe in getting divorced for XYZ yeah
you know I'll I'll give you abuse you
can leave
my only caveat is if you hit also it
doesn't yeah
omitted it doesn't count
and if he turns into a she he does the
he she thing what do you mean you know
when like the trans thing when he
becomes a woman or she becomes they
start cutting their parts on I feel like
they can get out I'll give you a get out
of them feel married and then they start
adding bits yeah like if you if you got
married and you became a man I think
that wouldn't really be fair
because at the end of the day I feel
like the people that don't believe in
divorce we should get married and not
believe in getting out and the people
that believe in divorce you guys can
just stay in the relationships and go
that route but then but then my question
to you is what if like your partner is
severely cheating and disrespecting you
and you know I agree with the divorce I
do agree
um but at the same time you know you
gotta know how you feel in a position
how you're made to feel and respect you
know maybe you know in that scenario how
would you take it if you're cheating
okay I think one women's definition of
severe cheating is so extreme it's like
oh he screwed one girl at the strip club
now it's a severe cheater okay
I think that we should try it should be
a goal to work through cheating it
should be the goal I think when you have
children it's not about you anymore your
feelings they don't matter and I think
that's true and so I think at the number
one goal work through it 100 you know
what's the limit
you know
um I would be quite mad if he got
another girl pregnant so that would be
awesome so cheat or you like but just
don't get anyone pregnant um my my goal
would be for him to not cheat on me
yeah but that's that's the question
though I think I think it's much more
deeper than cheating though is like the
reason for cheating no but it's the
disrespect though you gotta understand
how does it look to your family how does
it look to your kids if you've got kids
how's it look to your friends and well
you know what I mean for the women is
why do they all know he's not out there
tell I know damn well the men are not
out there telling everybody
yeah some men are not smart
that's why we should bring the fathers
back in to help their daughters pick
because we can't do it
we're incapable
I've actually asked my dad to help but
you're quite good at picking he refused
how so
um I just think all my boyfriends have
been like amazing like amazing men an
amazing boyfriend do you do you want to
be a mother yeah do you so do you have
kids or no no so it's like my question
is where where is the marriage and the
children then if they're I think because
I would think if they're amazing you
would you know I think my first couple
of boyfriends are amazing but I don't
think we were like perfect matches for
each other it doesn't exist
I think my current abortion is like a
very very good match okay so I am in
honeymoon period so okay so yeah so can
I can I get a wedding invite yeah okay
great I'll be at the wedding I'll be
there I just think like women need to
use their intelligence and self-control
a little bit more when they're choosing
man if they're getting uh messed around
[__] around like you just need to use
logic
um that's it I think even if I've maybe
like been a bit into someone I can get
turned off very quickly if I don't think
I've been treated well
um
turn back on I'll go for it yeah but
would you would you agree that by and
large women if we had to pick like 10
women the majority left to our own
devices
don't really make the best decisions in
men at least in our early 20s which is
when we have the most options
yeah myself
I think women always have options they
will always have options not well it
depends on a woman but I thought it
based everything on statistics sometimes
real life no but like I said no but see
where that conversation I was saying
like men can't like you know get laid
all the time like you've got to work for
it right women women can have options
you can go out and look good sometimes
you don't need to look good you can go
to the shop around the corner get your
milk and bread and you can get I can get
moved to by someone in a car you know
it's real you have many options and
that's what's that's the scary one I
think over the age of like I'm gonna
give women by and large
gone so we've got older crowds so so
um from okay by 30 your options
statistically have decreased by 50 as
women
um 90 of your eggs are gone so that's
another thing yeah
geriatric pregnancy starts at 35 yeah so
so that's another thing coming but looks
wise yeah women still can get it in
their 30s some women their 40s I think
50 but there's no there's no age limit
we're supposed to live to 90. like you
think women over 50 are really getting
hollered at by men they want some dude
it depends how you look and how you
present yourself like yep let's be real
you're a man yeah let's be real you know
it sometimes if a woman looks good if a
woman looks good she looks good okay can
we can we talk about the rules
what rule the rule the like the
exception or the rule do the majority of
women in their 50s get hollered at the
same amount as women in their 20s
okay okay yeah okay I hear what you're
saying I hear what you're saying but if
they look good they look good yeah yeah
that this is some woman this is what
they always do not not you know this is
just I've done enough they give some
woman that is a celebrity so she's
already hot yeah she's already in eight
nine or ten in her in her prime she's
also has all the access to the money
she's not the actor she's not the
average yeah there's exceptions you know
Jay I thought I thought it was going to
be JLo yeah
10 out of 10. I mean it depends though
it depends
I don't think it I don't think it
depends I think the majority it's a no
it's the it's not the same
I guess so
um
sorry just to go back a little bit
because I I did get cheated once because
he was still a very good boyfriend as in
like my family and friends some of my
friends but like but he's amazing to you
he's so doting like why would you want
to break up apparently it was a kiss
don't know for 100 but yeah so some
that's the baseball whatever he was an
amazing boyfriend I guess
he was apart from that so okay
he probably still was I'll give it to
him it was just just a one a one kiss
maybe apparently and and I did end up
break breaking out I did break up with
him we had a break then we go back
together and then I broke up with him
after but to walk to your point that
like you should be asked to get past
that
when I look back I don't regret it
because I don't want to be with him
because I love my boyfriend but I do
when I look back I'm like I can see the
love much more than I could then because
I was paranoid I had trust issues
I couldn't I couldn't really see
rationally how devoted he was until
after yeah
well we'll see or put in I I don't think
you know I think when you're in a
relationship that's different than a
marriage so I support if you want to
leave your cheating boyfriend go ahead
yeah yeah 100 years your choice thing is
once you have the children yeah you take
the vows it's not it affects the
children if you're married and you don't
have kids and he's cheating
I think the goal should be to work
through it I think that a lot of women
leave thinking they're going to do
better and a lot of times they end up
alone
um I get this especially from like the
like women will tell me like their moms
how they left their dads or something
and then it's like the Dad remarries the
mom doesn't is that a better situation
you know what yeah I can I can speak on
that because uh with my parents it
happened it was the same kind of
scenario I think it's more sort of the
man that ends up alone
because you gotta understand if they've
messed up a good woman it's hard to get
another good woman the way that they had
it in some aspects and I've seen it you
know what I mean so like like I said
when you come with me touch base again
on on women can have options not a lot
of men can you know what I mean so
it's a lot harder for a man sometimes to
find a good woman if you've got a good
woman and you're cheating on her and you
know now you want to settle down because
you come to an age or you feel lonely
you know it's a lot harder I'll be
honest over it so you know what's
interesting though the numbers will tell
you like differently because under the
age of like 35 or something it's like 75
of women are in relationships but it
switches when like men are over like 55
or something really so yeah so like men
will remarry more likely than women
I have a question okay so yeah do women
go for looks more than personality
nowadays huh well actually most of them
but I think maybe I was saying about
music let's be honest
but know what what I would go for
personality
but in some way yeah like can we can we
put a face to it thank you
I'm ready
give me two men a side by side thank you
but we don't know come on no but we can
say one is funny and one is a square
right I think so it is like looks bring
you in and then personality keeps you I
think both sides so then looks so then
it's the looks that's first because you
can't you know what I mean you know I
mean you can't be attracted to the
personality friend right and you've got
to know them over over a certain amount
of time yeah you didn't necessarily find
them attractive at first but because you
spent so much time with them
and then they're like you're back into
the bench and all this kind of stuff and
then that's what you see when you say
guys he's cute right yeah but and then
you start looking for it
boring they don't have I don't know who
you're talking to
foreign
[Music]
but you're right like if there's someone
that you work with like someone that
you're in their proximity it can grow
it can but then at the same time it
looks you're going to look at somebody
firsthand and be like oh this guy or
this girl looks good yeah of course let
me know a bit more about that person
that's what you know what I'm saying
yeah I gotta I gotta be honest looks
first it has to be
let's be real you make it like
personality first you're just not as
attract you know it's like come on you
just gonna friend zone that person right
in what context are we actually talking
about like I thought if a good looking
guy comes up to me you got him you got
him okay
all right yeah let's go let's go let's
go he's got brilliant personality though
yeah yeah yeah 100. and he is a dog this
does not work this does not work through
photos this is literally you get to know
something it says who we would pick
that's too amazing all right so you know
I mean he's got great personality and
he's a does yeah so what are you looking
at are you looking at the personality
then no but it's deeper than that like
I'm not talking about
yeah are we delusional here now
when you connect with that person it's
got nothing to do with over there what
would you go for the last personality
like I'm really sorry I don't know I
don't even know but you know what yeah
I'll be choosing I'll be honest one
guy's a comedian the other one guys yeah
but forget that yeah I'd be very honest
though there's been a lot of
relationships that I I've seen that yeah
they've with that person based on
personality and sometimes I wonder how
it's a beautiful thing because it's like
you know to connect energy wise whatever
it is a beautiful thing but then I I
kind of feel like well where does it go
how does a you know how did you attract
that person you said it could be a
friend but let's say it wasn't a friend
let's say that I'm approaching you let's
say I'm approaching you now hi Hi how
are you blah blah you're gonna look at
me before I speak
full of Attraction it has to be some
sort of so the looks has to be okay but
that's only if you're not in their
proximity yeah I agree with you if you
don't know the person let's bring you in
but yeah
with them or something I I have I have a
theory with that I wanted the ladies you
tell me if this is true okay so there's
immediate yes you see him a media yes
yeah yeah that's my type whatever
immediate no there is nothing the guy in
the no category could ever do to become
a yes yeah and then there's the maybes
okay so the maybes are like
depending on what he says he could be a
yes
and they're like oh I have to get this
yeah I have to get this yeah but he's
cute he's mine tonight and I guess come
on you speak like that I don't I don't
have one night stand so not he's one
mine tonight maybe he'll be mine there's
a lot of females I wouldn't want someone
that's really really really attractive
why not just wooden doesn't that make
you tingle like oh look at this
too
I feel like when women say this when
women in general I'm not saying you but
it's because they don't want to compete
for that guy it's like they would have
thousand percent they'd have to do too
much
like the girls are throwing themselves
at him it's just like we we don't need
that trouble in our lives
and be like oh I wonder what his booster
is like never
yeah but a lot of girls don't give that
the good looking guy or any guy or a
chance to even show personality so it's
almost like mate everybody's at the same
level
I mean everybody has been in it you know
what I'm saying you know like I haven't
always been successful let's be real
like everybody's been shot down like I'm
sure most women have two like it's not
you know but at the same time I it is a
good question because for me like I said
I've seen relationships where you know
how did they get together like she is a
10 and he's a minus five black it
happens way more it happens way more
that way around as well which is why I
think women do go for personality I more
than like stun men yeah yeah yeah well
also women find 80 percent of men as
unattractive not okay not he's all right
like they think 80 of men are ugly
really how why if they you know if they
see 10 men and they say do you find them
attractive they say no I do not at all
he's ugly to eight of them
you could do um there are some studies
where they just ask they show them
pictures and then when this is what the
women say or you can also look at dating
app data where women only swipe right
roughly five percent of the time
[Music]
we're men on the other hand they swipe
right 50 of the time we're like this
I'll think of us yes I'll finger hurts
has to do with the with the sex thing
where we can choose who we who we sleep
with who we see men can't as much so
they're probably just like they're
probably not looking for a relationship
where they're clicking 50 can I ask you
a question that's the number one that's
the number one way people are meeting
today and you could argue that nowadays
sex comes before relationships so in a
way so this looks the the sex is where
it starts right yeah I'm not happy with
this world yeah so the question I want
to ask you is all right so if
if um I don't know you're gonna have a
one-night stand on if you had a
one-night stand or whatever you're gonna
have be attracted by his looks rather
than his personality I don't have one no
no but if you would if you know what I'm
saying I'm not saying you have or I'm
not saying if you would but I'm saying
it would be your look the looks right I
need to connect more than their legs
that's why I don't have them because I
didn't even want to even if I thought
they were really attractive yeah I'd be
like I don't feel connected to you fair
enough you know it is
deeper I I can't understand I can't
understand that I think I think it's
just the the people that's here because
we're gonna have other women who would
say a different thing as a man would you
attract would you would you be a Woman
based on personality 100 everything she
ticks but she's not like your type like
I'm not saying she's ugly she's just
Intruder there's times like I've
approached a girl before my relationship
of course and get that in there
[Laughter]
when I woke up to you and you open your
mouth I'm like
no
as soon as you open them right now would
you agree she has to be over a certain
like Baseline they're like you ain't
dating no girl that's like 300 pounds
no yeah yeah this guy you know you don't
agree or yes you would date all right
300 pounds you dating her no okay okay
so there has to be like a basement yeah
that's just my preference yeah exactly
and everybody has their own time
sometimes I'm not bigger women so no is
that in stone yeah
okay so Caribbean Africa
I'm gonna break this down so so if men
if men really liked bigger women right
if that was the really their type why is
it when when men have all the options to
sleep with whoever they want money
status looks who do they pick a slim one
a slim woman slim woman I'm just going
I'm not going from statistics I'm going
from real life and experience and being
around you know
I'm saying
that like bigger women they usually
don't have options
hey that is Fox yes that is facts that's
the really yeah it's like the men that
are like oh I'm not picky well you can't
be
no I can't lie
I just want to check because are we
talking about obviously curvy girls are
appreciated but if it's big big then
yeah
well but also there is still guys that
like it but I don't think they're
they're in the minority 21 Stone
yeah I think actually they're in the
minority
that's 300 pounds 300 yeah that's a lot
21 Stone yeah
oh this kind of stuff oh whoa these guys
are not probably a small percentage but
there are like feeders and they love
fattening their women up but see this is
this is the problem right here that's
not you're the problem a little bit
respectful yeah because okay because
it's like you keep saying yeah yeah
because this is how we live in this
video Yeah respectfully because we keep
living we keep living in this clown
world of delusion because we keep
telling women oh there's some guys that
like that you don't look like that do
you know if you looked like that no guys
would be lining up you're you're
beautiful so I was like so it's like
you're you we're gonna have these
outcomes and if I said you look like her
you would be offended
I mean I mean
you would be so offensive imagine
imagine you got cheated on with her
I'll be like you can have him the thing
is I do I do have a couple of you like
beautiful friends that that do weigh a
lot in their personalities can I see you
can I see them
um I want to see if they're I won't show
the screen I just want to see like
between me and you you have your phone
no I just don't think I don't know
I'll show you after honestly like
she has the most beautiful face like
ever and she does have curves as well as
being overweight so that is definitely
guys that will like it and her
personality is it's one of the best
personalities I've ever met so I do
think she's still attractive and she
should be but I think she's an ex she's
probably an except yeah and also like my
my sister is is a larger lady and
she's beautiful she's spicy she's you
can see a picture absolutely stunning
because a lot of times we use these
words and when I see stunning I see like
eights sevens to tens that's like
stunning for me let me find it um
I would help my woman um to get fit on a
healthy
when she um was younger she did date
guys when I mean the when we go out I'm
not even seen like she's got a
she gets harassed by guys literally like
he's unreal and that's what I said
blessing I think this would be really
great to go into our next topic
there's nothing can you pull up the one
that says let me find it
the Isabella Riley Moody one sorry go
ahead just at one point can we go back
to like the mental health and well-being
of parents in the marriage but not now
but like whenever uh we could we could
do it real quick real quick what's your
what's your I think that
um happiness or well-being is really
important for a mom to have as well so I
think if they're not happy that can be
really damaging to the child as well and
I think that's a reason why splitting up
can be better I think that women should
figure out how to be happy
instead of leaving the marriage oh but
that's a bit
I think I think you're in control of if
you're happy so I think if you say he's
making me unhappy I think that's a lot
to put on a guy I think you should
figure out how to make yourself or even
your child yeah your child has nothing
to do with that yeah but making yourself
happy might be better and the
relationship so what go back to the
streets
you can still date like sometimes if you
really don't care when someone you're
really frustrated with someone just
seeing them every day is is difficult
and also there's a lot of there's a lot
of parents that stay together for the
kids that damage their kids there is I
do agree with that and like for me for
instance if I was if I was in a marriage
and I had a child and we decided to
split me personally I wouldn't bring
another man around that child for a long
time I wouldn't even be interested in in
dating like and it's easy for me to say
because I don't have children blah blah
but like I just I just wouldn't I'd want
to concentrate on that so so you know
the woman the woman
um
she says I want to be happy and then you
know what she does so most of the time
she gets cussed primary custody of the
kids so then they're in a single mother
home
um they're five times the the kids that
are brought up in single mother homes
are five times more likely to commit
suicide nine times more likely to drop
out of school ten times more likely to
abuse chemical substances 14 times more
likely to commit grape 20 times more
likely to end up in prison and 32 times
more likely to run away from home so
it's like but we don't know we don't
know when the Mother and Father Like
split up we don't know if the father is
present in that child's life of course
of course if the the father is not
present that's very damaging as well but
like you can split up and be amicable
and see you right and if the if the
number so I'm doing a documentary on the
court system here in the UK so I
actually know a decent amount about like
men getting custody so if they're lucky
they get custody six days a month
realize your numbers is important yeah
so only men only get primary custody 10
of the time and it's very it's not
common to get 50 50 split so usually
when the women leave they take the kids
and the men only get to see their kid on
weekends which is like what six to eight
days a month I've been through it yeah
I've been through what do you think
well um I agree but um I also disagree I
think fathers you need to understand
that you have a big part when you have a
you have a big place in a children's
life and in the system
they like to portray that the fathers
are not important but they are you're
just as much as important as you are as
you are as the mother it depends what
you bring to the table and how you are
and um you know your relationship with
your child and how you can provide and
XYZ so you know I've been through the
system with with uh my kids you know
um with my daughter actually with my
past relationship
um and we have shared custody uh on the
basis that I'm heavily involved and you
know financially and and just
spiritually physically I'm always
involved and I'm I'm catering to my
daughter's needs and you know
um but I feel like a lot of dance
nowadays they feel that they don't have
a voice or their voice isn't heard
because you know as you said a lot of
the time the women with my empowerment
When the Children over I mean you know
as primary carers but you know he was
just as much as a primary carer as the
mother so it's 50 your DNA you should
have right 100 how many men actually
care yeah a lot of men a lot of men
don't want full custody you know it's
it's funny um there are a lot of times
they'll use the stat like men don't
fight for their kids or some stat like
that but um the system's really hard to
get through so it's like the average guy
makes what 45
000 35 000 pounds a year and the thing
is if he so usually like if a woman goes
to a women's shelter basically what she
can do is claim that she was abused and
they get then get free counsel and you
know and even the women's shelters they
know that most of these are like false
cases oh yeah yeah most of these are so
men can't so that if the men have the
children can they not go to a shelters
another men's shelters where
so the women like they go to the
shelters and basically like so what the
thing that'll happen at the shelters is
they all have these stories that they
tell the women to say so if like he's
from a certain culture they'll say hey
say this this and this this will play in
court so like he if he's like from in
like I talked to one guy that was from
India so like he was so controlling I
did the religious stuff because he made
me and the thing is so now the crazy
thing is um so in this period She can um
Implement a restraining order so he
can't even see the kids and so
um when she does that like it'll take
six months to a year before he can even
go to court to fight the false like most
of the time it's not a real abuse
allegation so then she goes he goes to
court and then it's crazy because she's
coming in with a lawyer that's free and
he has to pay 20 to 30 000 to fight for
his kids that's right and he has a 10
chance of winning so he can either go in
without a lawyer or pay 20 to 30 000.
now on top of that the past year he's
been paying child support and on top of
that he's also been kicked out of his
house usually because if they have a
shared house she makes one call he's
kicked out so now he's homeless
um one guy I just talked to he lost his
job and his kids were a mile away and he
couldn't see them for a year and now on
top of that he has to spend all this
money to fight for his kids and maybe
get 50 if he's lucky he might see his
kids six days a month so a lot of guys
will just say like I honestly think the
single like the deadbeat dad is really a
myth and it's a lot of like bitter women
yeah can I just say something but a lot
of times people will hear the woman's
side of the story because remember in
the year the woman's in the kid's ear
saying oh your dad doesn't want to see
you I know like and the thing is I used
to I used to literally see it the other
way but remember we always listen to the
women's side and we always believed the
women and that's why you have to like
ask it like was there a police report
was there this because because like I
talked to the men on the other side of
it and so like and then on top of that
so let's say he fights like she in even
if she's proven to be lying he um he
can't um like she gets in no trouble and
the thing about abuse is they have a
point system now so the thing is she can
say coercive control is abuse and that's
and that's like literally if he says you
can't spend five thousand dollars on my
credit card that's like Financial
control and so basically it's like if
there's like a scale of 10 he just has
to get to a six and she could say oh he
was financially controlling he didn't
let me spend this one time he was
coercively controlling he said I
couldn't go to the club which are all
like reasonable things but like she can
go to court and say he was abusive now
the whole community thinks he's an
abuser and because everyone just
believes the girl and the thing is in
court it's not um about guilty until
proven it's not about evidence it's
about a balance of probabilities so
basically like it's not based on 100
fact so she goes to court everyone
thinks she's an abuser he's a lot he's
paying all this money he can't pay and
and he gets a 10 shot at his kids even
if he unless he wins
um the court case which he probably
won't she can also um like let's say the
judge says Hey six days a month you can
see the kid he then gets his
um child six days a month she can make
another call and do it again for another
year now I used to spend another 30. it
takes a lot for a woman to go through
that to like influence must play a big
path in that you know what it is
influence that's actually causes you
must think you're yeah that must be like
quite a lot of beef to go to court
because you could actually sort that
civilly did you go to court listen I
went to court with my um my baby mother
my first yeah my first child and exactly
what you said that's spot on do you
think she was spot on do you think do
you think she was influenced oh 100
they're the women
you have to follow the money and the
thing is like the lawyers don't help the
women's group because the Lord so you
could go to a lawyer to get help and
they're not going to help you because
their number one client is the women's
groups I mean look at this I was in
court and most of the judges prosecutors
were women yeah so they already looked
at me and judged me you know so already
I already lost the battle before I
suppose
they just like believe her 100 because
then we have this culture like believe
always oh yeah that's it why did she
take you to court was it a typical day
well basically um you know we split up
so you know
um
again to get the um money no no so so
basically it's a thing where like um
I I strongly believe that um some women
don't get over their Partners you know
them splitting up for whatever reason
hard to split up whatever reason some
people can't get over it so influence so
um you know they use their their
children as a weapon so in a way where
they want to punish you for hurting them
in a way where I want you to feel how I
feel but ten times worse you know so
that's the evil side of of a
manipulation and also control so it
makes the man feel that oh I have no
access to my child I can't do anything
you know yeah exactly so it's almost
like I'm I'm either with you and I see
my child or if I'm not with you I can
only see my child that you'll say so I
do I do think that's disgusting like
because before you said before you said
that obviously I kind of realized that
was a reason but I was thinking why
would I ever not let my the father of my
children see my kids and that's the
thing there are some women that are very
willing for the for the dad to see the
children
but the thing is too I think it's the
exception it's not the rule because I
think the whole like the last 50 years
we've only heard the woman's side that's
right because especially like even it
happened to Kanye he loved his mom yeah
it happened before like before our eyes
where he always thought his dad was a
deadbeat when really his mom moved away
from him that's the other thing like
there's no like if the woman just wants
to take the kid there's one guy that his
his um his baby his ex-wife moved to
Japan wow Japan like there has to be
something legal like you can't move but
you know what it is yeah like you said
you clear it's very easy to say oh he's
a deadbeat but nobody understands the
side of his story because you know I
actually mean by dead dead as in as in
like you're not present you don't do
anything you you know you let go of your
child and you don't want nothing to do
with the child but you know a lot of the
time it's a lot harder to be involved
when you're so pushed out yeah you know
but some sometimes you have part-time
dads that sometimes see you they will
come and see you every now and again
when they're free when they're available
you've got some dads that literally live
their life they've separated from the
partner and their family and they're
going out and they're living their best
life and big up all the single moms by
the way because that is a very yeah
big down because it was your life choice
and you shouldn't have did that you
should have stayed with the father or
you could be no no no no no no no no no
because some men will walk out on their
women and the women would be on their
names
it's the exception and of course like
those women half the time they pick men
that have impregnated like three girls
and you're like well of course he's
gonna like what did you expect it's not
always the case I would say it's more
often the case than not
and plus women women leave more
statistically yeah but there is those
men that like will be happy to have that
woman there and happy to like use them
to stay at their house Etc and then
expect to see three people at the same
time so obviously the woman's gonna get
frustrated that's the man that you chose
yeah I blame that on the woman because
blame so much on the women
I don't get it yeah but it's not there's
no blame thing it's like you go to your
process before you actually get okay
what is this like we're blaming the
women for a lot of things that actually
some men are heavily responsible because
we're kids
okay which which part which part is mad
you don't think you're so if you have a
child aren't you responsible for picking
the father isn't that your fault facts
he said that's what I'm trying to say
unless you get in trouble we agreed we
agreed the women are in control of sex
right yeah right women are correct
no spots you get pregnant if you're not
in a relationship and you're single and
you're you you want to find someone to
have sex it's easier for a woman to go
out and find that in a relationship it's
a partnership you're both responsible so
another question who knows
so I have a question I have a question
who who who knows when you're ovulating
does he know when you're ovulating no no
no ovulating I mean now
Cycles
no I I think it's about I need you to
ask that just just in general do do men
know if the women are ovulating or do
women know if the men are ovulating
that's just which one who knows more
some women don't know okay can we talk
about in general general in general okay
the women come on come on
the women that I'm around we know and we
talk about that with the people that we
are interested we can use protection
anyway let's continue let's continue so
so let's let's continue
um do do we know a foreign birth control
or do the men know if we're on birth
control yeah we know okay so I was
imagined I wouldn't be sleeping with
someone without protection over yeah
okay so so do do we get to choose if we
get an abortion or do the men get to
choose if we get an abortion oh that
depends though
that really does depend they should the
men shouldn't be sleeping with someone
without protection it's still a choice
right now we can get to the men okay we
can get to them later can we just get to
the women first okay all the women
though it depends whether you were
tricked because yes if you if that man
is obviously not going to be good to you
it I do personally think it is cheapest
to have a child well sorry that's a bit
I'm just asking about the choice like do
the men get a choice and if we get an
abortion or not I'm asking about the
choice it depends so okay how does the
man get any say does he get to um
because it could be a thing where they
can manipulate the woman and say look I
don't want to be I don't want to be a
follower if you don't they could
convince her but at the end of the day
who gets to pick the manner of the women
of course is the woman okay so that's my
point so okay so now who gets to pick if
we get an IUD or not who gets to pick if
we take a plan b or not so if we get to
do all this picking don't you think we
should take more of the responsibility
like it's more on us since because when
we have sex right we know if they're
wearing a condom or not but the men
don't know if we're on birth control or
not so we're the only we know if we're
ovulating or not where the men don't
know if we're ovulating or not so we're
the one with all the information where
the men don't always have all the
information men know that women do baby
trap sometimes so just use protection
like I feel like it's a shared
responsibility
I would say it's more on the women for
picking who you have a child with do you
know what I I like this because I have
daughters so I I'm trying to I'm
learning all of this so you're not
you're right I feel like you're really
right because at the end of the day you
communicate with whoever they're dealing
with that was yeah I know but like you
said it is the woman like let's be
respectful here but like at the end of
the day it is the woman's control to
have something grow in her in a way you
know if you want to have a baby you can
be like I'm having a baby with or
without you that's my decision
is not ready but then you still make the
choice you know if you know you're gonna
have unprotected sex you should prepare
it for that I've made the decision if
you go in and have I'm pretty sex you're
both consenting adults you you have
brain cells some women don't think like
that but women are 100 in control of
who's born yeah men are just in control
of who they have sex with but women are
100 in control who gets born I agree
that they shouldn't they uh
my question is then why are you having
unprotected sex with men who shouldn't
be fathers yeah that's my question
that is a good point but what if what if
they've um made you think that they're a
good guy this is hasn't actually
happened to me but but that's the
woman's judgment though
in a way what if they've made you think
that okay I guess I'm sorry baby should
be like step 10 all right yeah
so like it's like what were you doing
you should have babies
ideally with 50s girl making a baby not
as in marriage first and then you don't
think you want to get married times have
changed okay well times have changed
you know what I'll be honest with you
yeah I think it is better to get married
and have children reason why is because
there's more stability yeah there's more
like okay we put each other first we are
loyal to each other first and we've made
something sand and sealed we can now you
know conquer life
you know the whole having babies out of
wedlock always seems to be the reason
why a lot of relationships fail and
that's and that's that's you know I'm
not going to say it's facts but I'm
saying that's my opinion but for me it's
a thing where you know if you're married
you already built already a foundation
of of how you're gonna raise your child
and your child is going to look at you
too and be like okay well you look on my
my example of how I should you know live
my life and meet somebody and and kind
of do the same thing I hope we're
talking about what can be changed
because this generation right now is
that's another topic language
yeah you can marry and settle down with
and do all that then
good for you I don't think it's that
hard to be honest really yeah teach me I
think well I teach I think a lot of
women I love the way you speak it's just
it's not that deep yeah yeah it's not
that deep no don't get me wrong don't
get me wrong
um it is hard to find a guy that meets
all of your requirements
as a woman I will say we're all pretty
picky high standards yeah yeah in
general let's just let's just call a
spade a spade here women are picky men
are not as picky and I do think it is
hard for women to find a guy that meets
all their requirements but okay so if a
guy if if you're saying okay I can't
find a guy that meets my requirements
well it's maybe you're not good enough
so you should probably try to be better
um or or maybe lower the requirements
and get a guy that's on your level I
would say those are you know if nobody's
buying you got to figure out what's the
problem yeah and either fix the problem
or lower what you want lower your price
there's also a lot of women that go for
guys that are emotionally unavailable
that's out of their league and they
stick with it I think it's out of their
league yeah that's what I think I think
when they say emotionally unavailable it
just means he doesn't like me that much
she's only there for his looks yeah yeah
so like she's a five six maybe a seven
going for a nine or a ten and he's
emotionally unavailable because he
doesn't like her I just want one thing
there's some guys though if they've
experienced trauma they've got trust
issues like really deep trauma or trust
issues they the women could be anything
and actually they still wouldn't be able
to maintain it because they would
perhaps see be avoiding or their
subconscious words because they're
afraid of Abandonment and stuff like
that I do think women sometimes pick men
that aren't husbands yeah and then get
surprised when they don't act like
husbands when he wasn't that's very true
husband he doesn't want to be married I
don't know why we're surprised that it's
like it's like you can't pick uh you
can't take a wild animal and and expect
it to be a pet like you know what I'm
saying it's gonna be wild now it's gonna
happen it's nature you know what I'm
saying it's going to come out with this
Randomness as women we're all screwing
the same guys yeah yeah yeah fun fact
women just as a group or we're all
screwing the same then is it not the
same with men though yeah yeah man the
same women
um probably not because they'll take
anyone more like not really because you
don't need to have women women typically
go for 20 of men
typically what do you mean what do you
mean so um women if we list our
requirements I've done we could even do
the delusion calculator it's a lot of
fun
delusional do you want to see this this
way
no I'm not gonna uh it's okay most women
are you're not alone but don't don't
feel like you're right
we're learning so much right now yeah
lots and lots of delusion so this is the
female delusion calculator
yeah we can do it
age are you looking to date
um 30 upwards 30 to what 70. oh God
yeah okay yeah also a fun fact fun fact
fun fact I found out found out yesterday
I was like maybe I'll start dating
younger because if men don't get married
no if men don't get married over the age
of 35 apparently there's only a 15
chance they'll get married ever because
they're emotionally available
no because we've all made ourselves so
available
um running the streets or whatever it's
Street in so the Met it's like what why
would he settle down when there's 10 of
you you know for real if you're dating
let's just say 45 is the oldest yoga for
right okay 49 49.
10 years into your relationship are you
going to be attracted the same way to
that guy
that's true that's a good question yeah
but people as I said earlier like people
change like even if you date someone
younger in 10 years that you might not
find them attractive she will now now
let's go let's keep going excluding
marriage
are you into the married guys no okay no
married men for her go down
what do you mean married men like as in
he's married
a guy is in a relationship of any type
the attraction is gone okay fine yeah
because so now let's talk about race
white black Asian or any black okay only
black mine would be okay do you next
time
[Laughter]
how tall does he have to be be nice I
mean I'm five four and a half so
um five eight up five eight that's I've
gotten that minimum a lot about five
eight okay obese men okay no thank you
no obese I'm just curious how many
ex-boyfriends have you had just curious
play four four um how tall were they
the six foot yeah so so cap let's move
it up to six foot
exactly
all right they keep going
minimum minimum income okay minimum
income
how much does he have to how much does
he have to make oh what oh do you know
what I'm really bad with this I've
always kind of been the breadwinner
um
she like broke hot guys huh
and that's another word
okay you're not alone
maybe I should have standards okay
should we actually put okay what do you
mean that that is a standard you'd like
that oh you'll see what percentage how
much does he have to make okay
um
it's quite a bit higher so say about 55
okay so uh that's all broke 55. hey
that's money okay that's good money okay
with her ideal though not her including
her ex who's is that what I mean my exes
have never earned that amount of money
by the way I'm just like okay okay let's
make a real let's make a real realistic
yeah 40 or something realistic realistic
mine is probably 12 say 35.
so go down go down now now let's
calculate what percent of men are you
looking for now this is what I mean when
I say we're all screwing the same then
now this is why okay go
yeah
so oh so yeah so um you know yo I like
you you seem like a great gal but you
might die alone yeah yeah I think I
might have to like open yeah
four out of five a cad enthusiasts this
is interesting man because now we get to
the relationship stage right now is that
man gonna like get married to you right
probably not
that's the problem this is why 50 of
women are projected to be single and
childless and die alone because if
that's hot damn yeah so now okay your
turn now she seems very interesting you
know I genuinely hope it works out this
is very interesting we can do the nail
delusion too please
what age
26. oh she's trying to make it she means
36. no honestly I don't mind doing
younger guys
45. 45 okay really 2012. I think I have
the same age requirement as you that's
roughly mine yeah okay go down go down
uh married no no no no 10 years later
race
um so I'm assuming we're including
Arabic in Asian
you you could put any you could put any
maybe I should have done that in the
color actually okay so I'm very tall I'm
nearly five eleven so obviously some
like Asian countries like a
stereotypically shorter but
um in Arabic I've dated probably five
seven minutes but what is your
attraction now what you're like okay so
which one do you which one do you like
what do you actually like
um any I guess if it's just out of them
yeah yeah
minimum height five seven
really wow how tall are you nearly five
eleven I guess you see that I don't see
that yeah but you see that because that
girl's tall if a girl's taller than me
I'd feel like I'm not that she ain't
gonna be looking at me like okay you
know what I'm saying it's a bit do you
know why because I try to live my life
outside of being shallow so I've I've
been on a dating app before and I'm
chatting to a guy like I like him he's
his personality is great he also has
basic he was in the Army then he decided
he didn't agree with war so he was going
to like train
um Range Rangers in Uganda to stop
poaching so I really liked his values
and stuff that's awesome okay but it was
obvious he was sure I I need I need okay
so five seven obese yes or no
no okay all right minimum income
on a run to 20. okay that's 30 UK
roughly or 30. I've also I've changed
jobs I used to be in a job that I got
paid much more and I was more open to
guys that earn less at that time because
logically at
12.00
because I picked any black guys but you
see you see how I'm saying we're all
screwing the same the same men 12
percent
one of my friends is five two or five
one and she only dates guys
it makes no sense
you're really not because it's only 12
of men well compared to the average
female apparently that's what is that
top one or two I think I think the
highest of what is the highest we've
gotten like 20
because
wow 27 that was the highest did they
include obese I don't know what is what
is the two the phone okay can you do the
female delusion car the male delusion
calculator what is the tuna you go first
yeah I don't mind well I just I just
want to ask this question for like what
is the turn of on height I feel like
it's a delusion of females a man has to
be six foot like he has to be that's
true that's crazy you know what you know
what it is with that yeah then what it
is with that yeah yeah it's like a man
can't change his hat but he can change
his weight so to say that I don't like
small men or I like two men or whatever
how does it affect that man you know
what I'm saying what about height yeah
and I have to just be honest I feel like
I'm trying to breathe breed athletic
children
don't you think that's delusional I
think it's more
options it might be
um yeah I mean he could be a little
shorter than me but it fits a lot I just
feel like I'm like I need the kids to be
tall oh yeah because like sports are big
in my family I was an athlete and I'd
like my kids to play sports do you know
it is a funny thing that one of my
friends said uh the reason why he
doesn't they Tula women is because uh
Fair rejection no it feels like a child
like I can't explain like because she
could like pick him up yeah like the
masculinity is just like I feel like a
boy is you know like I think under five
seven I would feel do you get what I'm
saying yeah you know what I mean so it's
a bit
five eight five seconds it's okay but
I'm like much short I just can't we're
not dating like really skinny guys I
don't mind
26 to 25. okay 26 35
26 to 35 is that what you said
okay I'm married
unmarried mothers
no no we didn't have that oh is it for
real yeah
I would have appreciated that okay any
race
any
okay Hispanic you know height
okay so I'd go for
five foot two
five ten
five foot two or five foot two five ten
six two
fair enough
five foot five blessing
um overweight no
obese no okay minimum income
20K
okay
20. oh yeah that's in the US that's 30.
all right let's see how delusional he is
let's see
2.72 percent
hmm
interesting
so does that mean yeah delusional you're
delusional okay so you're not as
open-minded basically right aspiring
Bachelor three out of five red pills
aspiring Bachelor
male reality
I wonder okay your turn me
um
I think it was the age for that one
no you know what is here
and yeah we had this discussion of area
but I'll be rule it depends how you look
it depends your mindset thank you so for
me I can't say an age and be like yeah
she's just she's expected to be her age
because I've met younger girls that I'm
more mature than girls of my age right
so that's fine I say for me it depends
on age so
um mentally so I say
for me we don't we don't see men for
dating younger women I say as you should
King as you should you know I know but
there's a limit though in it so it's
like 100. it depends
like if you're 18 you're legal not on
their children no but in this country is
16. that's right okay no no no but I'm
not saying I'm just saying like not even
21 minutes so all right cool I feel like
women honestly shame men for dating
younger women as a way to compete with
the younger women I feel like I feel
like I think it's a stigma of all your
life you know you're dreaming they're
better looking
um they're usually in better shape no
they're not um they're usually had less
sexual partners okay okay let me answer
my question this is my this is my uh my
opportunity all right so I say over 21.
okay 21 don't judge me yeah I think
that's a reason
hmm
I'll be honest
I wouldn't date a woman older than me
so like for me
it kind of she kind of I don't know I
think okay give me the age give me that
actually I would but it wouldn't be that
drastically like older than me if that
makes 35 not that far from you I'm 32.
so for me ish you have to be
Maybe 35.
yeah I don't mind okay so bring the moms
back in Mary you're trying to steal
steal a wife
I wouldn't break up a happy family or
even a family that's what I'm saying so
I'm not enough okay race any
okay keep going hype
uh I'm not exactly six foot
[Music]
all right cool so I don't mind a girl
taller than me it's just for me I I feel
like I feel that um some like you know
like you can relate a lot of women like
men taller than you know than them so
for me it's like I don't genuinely uh go
for women that are taller than me for
that basis or for that uh you won't be
offended go ahead yeah so what's your
height what's your height
um
I say
like I can't I don't really know about
heart but how tall are you
five ten and a half so like yeah so I
wouldn't mind the woman that that's that
tall basically okay yeah okay so five
ten or five five eleven ten eleven okay
go to five eleven five foot or lowest um
height I'll say four
I'll say um no minimum height just not a
[__] like what's yours it's not a
[__] yeah so yeah man yeah 11 or
something yeah yeah it's not a [__]
it's just not it would be called
but I'm not two so she wouldn't be a
[__] to me you know what I'm saying
yeah that's right all right go down um
overweight and obese I'm assuming that's
not gonna go all right minimum income
I'm not really that bothered to be
honest let's let her be unemployed I'm
actually not bothered but as long as she
contributes or you just don't care I
don't actually care because uh okay go
down I don't yeah it's not like oh she
has you know I mean for me all right
ten percent so what does that mean that
means uh delusional wow that's
delusional well hold on wait a minute
I'm down to earth so I'm not delusional
how did I get Bachelor though
you play a player I don't know I'm just
going off the website you know what I
mean it means that you will go for 10.78
of women is that right yeah well ten
point out of the whole population so if
you only
go for one percent you know what they
should do they should take out like over
50s because they shouldn't be dating
anyways well over 50s
yeah man I'll give men a pass but women
what are we doing on the dating Market
over 50.
I really think the man should be on the
dating walk it over why because like
dating and love is a young person
what's wrong what is wrong with you that
you are still single in your 50s that's
true and she just said what's wrong with
you men ask this okay honestly men ask
this in your late 20s like why are you
still single because the best women get
picked below like 25 let's just let's
just call Spade spade and this is me I'm
over 25 and I hope today I'm 26. okay
and I could say the best women that were
the most desired from college are
married but first marriages are more
likely to end than second marriages
that's not true actually the second and
you're more likely to get divorced every
time you get married
and so so he was going through some
questions online no that it was finished
yeah you got 12. yeah we did already we
did our delusion so who's more
delusional
the women so what was you again no it
was it was actually yeah absolutely
I'm the bachelor yeah yeah he's he might
be he's in the delusion too who me no
I'm down to earth I think she was got
the what did you get I got the
a lot of times people say they'd want
these things but then they don't always
date those you know it's like sometimes
it happens
um why do I think women shouldn't be
dating in their 50s yes
um I think that if you're selling a car
right now I'm not saying women are cars
but I'm gonna use it in analogy to
compare us to cars okay now if a car has
high mileage now if the car has been on
the market no for 30 years if the car
has been on the market for 30 years I
can say one it's had a lot of test rides
and two why are you still on the market
at 50. that's a lot of time to figure
out how to sell yourself because
sometimes
life doesn't work out the way that you
think it or expect it to be you could be
dedicating your life to your kids and
making sure that they're okay because
your husband walked out on you and
remarried and had more kids and you've
been focusing on your kids and making
sure I gotta I gotta I gotta be honest
here what do I think of when I hear this
okay well that he walked out on me
[Music]
right there is the problem with women
because we think we didn't do a damn
thing
men will spend hours studying asking
what went wrong all this stuff women say
I did nothing wrong to make him leave
you know what it is point two why I also
think that women when they get left it's
worse because if a man leaves he's
losing half his [__] he's also losing
his children most likely so if he leaves
you I'm thinking this must have been a
living hell for him to leave you no it's
not always the case and I understand why
you would come to that conclusion I
really do but
it's not always the case I never said
always um you know there's
um you know there's Miracles like things
happen right
but in general
um yeah I I question why but especially
in younger marriages
like if you get married for instance in
your 20s
you haven't even
had the opportunity to get to know who
you are as a human being as a person on
this Earth what your purpose is and what
you're doing in life like I understand
that tradition you you find someone you
get married in your early 20s you have
kids
I don't necessarily know if that's the
right thing that people should be doing
now because I don't know where that came
from like I don't know whether that came
from
but this might sound stupid yeah I don't
know whether this is even a real thing
but
back in the day
especially like grandparents ages when
they were in like the war times and
staff I would imagine life expectancy
was a little bit lower so when you are
looking to create a family and have kids
of course you're going to be doing that
at a younger age because life expectancy
was lower where nowadays what time
period are you talking about so like for
instance my my I'm pretty sure my
granddad was like in World War II not in
like literally fighting but like he was
since the 1800s men live to be 75 and 73
for women
I'm just I'm just looking I don't know
if these are true or not I don't know I
don't even it's not facts I haven't
looked this up it's just kind of well
logic you know so I got it you said a
couple things I forgot what the first
one was that I wanted to say something I
probably forgot too women
don't remember sorry can I just say
something yeah go ahead you know like
when you said um a lot of the times it's
kind of like
not not in a I'm trying to say it
respectfully but blaming the woman for
why the man left yeah I think personally
um it depends yeah but at the same time
a lot of times
apart from past experience I feel like a
lot of women get a bit too comfortable
and a lot of women then turn down turn
down their their level of trying to to
be attractive to their man or try to be
um available to their man because let's
be real as a man yeah yeah you go work
and whenever you've got good wife at
home whatever you're gonna see women
everywhere yes as a man and the Brain
the man's mind is a lot different to a
woman's man yeah so I'm not saying that
oh I'm cheating or I'm looking but you
know it's not saying it's hard to ignore
but you're gonna see there's always
going to be more people more women
attractive than your woman yeah so what
I'm saying
yeah of course of course but at the same
time I feel like from past experience
from you know a lot of women from my
past experience is my opinion
um I feel like a lot of women get
comfortable and they feel that they they
don't have that they don't no no but
they don't have to do so much and effort
wise they don't have to look as good as
how I met you and do the thing
I think it is literally equal like I had
a conversation the other day with a guy
and um he basically said that since he's
been married he just stopped going he
stopped going to the gym he just stopped
yeah I do think there is a pandemic I do
think I agree I do think the men do it
too I want to say something yeah I I
know a couple uh they go to my gym
um
I personally think that in a marriage
you as you said you don't want to get
too comfortable because you want to be
excited to go home and actually see that
person so this couple they wake up
together they do business together they
travel together they do basically
everything together and they always keep
it fresh they would never go to the same
country they will never do the same
Miracles they'll always do something new
they'll Venture new businesses they all
know care of each other they unlock new
experiences experiences yeah so that's
what I was seeing before like it all
boils down to Choice an effort like they
choose to be happy with each other
honestly yeah I remembered I remembered
what I was gonna say I remember you said
you don't really know yourself in your
20s and what I was gonna say is we're
supposed to grow together and become one
marriage is supposed to be too flesh
become one that's like the biblical
thing you know so so I think for the
people that don't want to grow together
you guys should just stick to your
relationships and the people that think
you should get divorced for everything
you guys should that's fine go stick to
the relationships where us who don't
believe in divorce should be over here
yeah I think I agree with that but I'm
glad that I didn't marry early because I
think you can have like a more varied
life but can I ask you a question though
because I feel like what if one of your
boyfriends
uh did propose to at the time that you
said they were great and you know like
obviously things can be good at the time
like I'm not saying you know it is it's
a bad thing but at the same time
I feel like nine times out of ten it's
mostly the men that proposed to the
women that want to commit yeah so what
if
they wanted to commit what would you say
at the time he was ready or like you
know what I'm saying
actually oh I have a question I have a
question if if you and do you want kids
I'm assuming right yeah most women do so
what if what if um you got tested
tomorrow and you you no longer could
have kids because you waited too long
would you still be happy with that
decision
that would obviously be really sad and I
would
I don't know I'd have to think about
that question because I would I would
adopt if I um there are other options
exactly it's not just biological yeah
but there's a lot of problems there
everyone's Minds options and I know it
because we've both given up for adoption
like in my family we gave up a kid for
my parents I got pregnant when my mom
was 17 so they gave up their first kid
and then we adopted three later there's
a lot of problems that come with
adoption like it's not really an
identity kind of yeah it's not really
good for a kid to like take it from its
mothers and give it to the street but it
could be better than it growing up in
care it probably is yeah it 100 is
better than growing up in Terror but I
think the ideal okay I think the ideal
is to stay with the guy that you had the
kid with
get married do the shotgun wedding and
stay together forever yeah but the thing
is if you can't have kids too but if
they can't have kids oh okay well if
they can't have kids that's the only
option they came they can kind of have
really yeah no then you know what I mean
that's true I mean I think that's like
that's what I would do if I couldn't
have kids but but my question more is
like we say like to wait you don't know
yourself in your 20s but it's like when
you're older you're kind of playing
roulette like you said you're 33 so
geriatric pregnancy starts for you at
35. and after that it's high risk so
it's like now you're in a new
relationship and you have all this
pressure where if you start in your 20s
it's less high pressure for the guy but
don't you think it's a lot of pressure
for women to just okay if I'm not if I
don't have a kid that 30 then I must
have a kid regardless
that you still have time no not really
though because you have a lot of time
you have that pressure in your mind then
you you have to but I think I mean feel
it regardless for the most part like I
mean you can't you have to know that on
some level that you tend to be more
rushed in your 30s I think society makes
it so much harder for women to just be
in general just just be just be a woman
just be human just be because there's
all these rules you've got to do this by
this age
um you've got to be married by this age
and if you don't get married then you're
this type of woman and if you don't look
like this then you're this like
everything a woman does with scrutinize
for I disagree I think everything a
woman does were praised for I don't know
what where would you live I live in this
one so yeah you know we're in this world
where women can get fat and then we're
like body positive you're beautiful
anyways no you know what it's because
there's different Generations oh my god
let's know
this is this different generations and
this is when it comes down to age and
and different way of world like you know
something I want to say you know what
I'm saying say it say it say it actually
wait so and you also said that women are
like expected to be married by a certain
I just think it's like basic supply and
demand
you know the best women tend to get
married younger it doesn't mean you're a
bad woman with the better women yeah
yeah yeah yeah if you're selling a car
don't you think the best product gets
taken off off the shelf immediately
we're not cars it's not good I kept I
kept saying that I'm not saying that
works yeah yeah so I think it depends on
your values because there are some girls
that since they were young they've
always dreamed of getting married and
having kids they're more likely to have
children I think those are the better
women
yeah in what way that there are better
women they're better for society and how
how would they how are they better for
society because they they have kids and
their great mothers because they've
always wanted to be mothers and that was
their number one goal and they're
usually better wives because they
prioritize the family and I'm not you
know because a lot of people will come
at me and say well what about you well I
can admit there are better women than me
yeah
yeah and it is just an opinion an
opinion is not factual opinion you know
I mean it could just be an opinion it is
but I think it's just common sense if
I'm being honest don't you think that
the best mothers have always wanted to
be mothers especially as a child
I think they romanticize it I think they
think it's going to make their lives and
be the best thing ever a lot of um
people have children earlier because
they're actually not that satisfied in
life of themselves and they think it
will fix it and it doesn't whereas like
I I think you shouldn't do that to fix
your life have a child I say don't do
that but I say the women that want to
get married have children early young
those are the best if I my brother's
looking for a girl I'm saying pick that
woman not the woman that wanted to wait
till her third woman what about a woman
that's been a victim of grape and she
has to to to literally you know some
women have to you know someone make the
decision to keep the child or you know
or whatever
you know me my first question did she go
to the police regardless regardless
those are completely different
situations but some women keep the child
because maybe health reasons you're
talking about getting pregnant yeah
right that's what we're talking yeah so
it's to raise a child you know some some
women weren't great mothers
so what's your question so my question
so what my question is you're saying uh
only the great women deserves I said the
best the best women get married the best
women would have you know the options of
you know getting prayer you know having
kids married or whatever she would want
that she would want that but some women
don't necessarily want that and they
have fallen into that situation where
they're having to take on their
responsibility and having to change
their lifestyle so in that way so if my
brother was picking two girls and one um
was a virgin 22 and one was the same
single mother I'm from from grape I
would say pick the 22 year old virgin
because I would say that's a better pick
because you don't want to deal with all
of the trauma that's going to come with
her I have a lot of empathy for her I
think that's a sad situation to be in
but if I'm if I'm talking to my brother
and I think most of you would probably
say the same thing that you don't want
to raise 100 another dude's kid even
though it's a really sad situation that
she was in yeah big up to her for
keeping the kid I think that takes a lot
it takes a Mando to do that it depends
on how the personality and your
connection though like that's what I
think should I override it I get what
you're saying I I don't think it should
over I think it I think like the way
we're speaking right now is as if
someone have a kid like you run out of
time like you still have time
we have to still have time to eat to
grow you still
um
we all live life with Free Will and
choices if you choose to want to have a
baby today or the next 10 years that's
up to you it doesn't change the
perception of who you was a woman
I think that's
false yeah fair enough because I think
that when if you have if you're a single
mother men are less likely to date you
than if you're not a single mother
hmm okay I can understand that because
you're more desirable you're more you're
more like okay
I can build from someone from scratch I
can get that but at the same time it
doesn't make a woman any less valuable
or or desirable because she has a next
it doesn't actually have a child you
just said it does make her less
desirable you just contradicted yourself
how did I do that because you were just
saying you understand why she would be
less like wanted on the marketplace
yeah of course but at the same time it
doesn't mean that she's actually like
undesirable to some men may have a
higher expectation and think okay I want
a woman as a virgin I want a woman with
no kids because maybe I have no kids or
maybe I have kids and I want to start
fresh but it doesn't necessarily mean
that a woman is undesirable to 99 of men
has to know if he could handle it before
you go into a relationship of course
yeah but you would agree that in general
men will pick no kids before they pick
raising another man's kids it depends on
their situation you would say can we can
we please please please my personal
opinion in general I say I say it
depends on the situation because I have
kids and my partner has a kid so for me
it was a no-brainer for me to pick a
woman that has no kids she might not be
a good mother role to my child so where
does it leave me as a man knowing that
this woman is left I've left this woman
with my child and my child is not you
know being taken care of lack a mother
would do or you know what I mean if you
were if you were my brother you're and
he was in your situation right I would
still tell him to pick the girl with no
kids because she clearly has made a poor
choice if she's in that situation and so
yeah but it doesn't matter we're all
humans we make mistakes that doesn't
mean that we're less than a person I
would say that if you can you pick the
people that have made less mistakes no
but the thing is why would you want
someone that's made more mistakes rather
than less mistakes I understand what
you're saying but at the same time
you've got to look at your situation
it's it's like you know if you've got a
child it makes sense if you meet
somebody that has a child you can both
relate on that okay you know what I mean
I will I will say that in my opinion
people with kids should date each other
right I do somewhat agree yeah however I
think if a guy can swing it if he's got
kids and he can get a girl with no kids
I would say take no kid look it's a bit
different for a man if you want to look
at it that way because you know and
another you know on another hand you can
say oh I'm a man that has no kids why
should I raise another man's child why
should I pay for this man's child why
should I put up with a Man
Too that you're in a situation where
like you could get close with like
daughter son whatever and then you have
no rights you could raise that kid for
10 years you got no rights to it exactly
so so they're the pros and cons yeah so
it's like wow so as a guy why would you
pick that when you could pick not that
but I feel like a woman's values are a
lot different than a man so like you
know you know going back on topic on you
know I I'm with somebody that has a
child because she understands how to
raise a child and come from a family
home not to say not to say that a woman
that is single with no kids doesn't
understand it but in some respects he
does it in a way you need to prioritize
your children as well right so you know
in a way it's a no-brainer it's like you
know women are naturally you know in my
opinion I'm gonna say this in fact don't
shoot me but you know they tend to you
know naturally be mothers it's some
somewhat mothers to some relationships
as well you know so it's a no-brainer in
a way to pick a woman with a child well
I'm not saying there's no single mothers
that can be dated right and in your
situation sure but I still go back to if
it was my brother I would tell him if he
could swing it pick the girl with no
kids because you don't want to deal you
don't want to deal with another if he
has a kid or if he doesn't both I would
say if my brother has a child and he he
has the choice to date not everyone has
that choice but if he has a choice girl
with no kid or girl with kid I would say
no kid but you just said before that you
think that a guy with a child and a
woman with a child should date each
other no I think
would date each other in general
both on both ends We should strive to
date people without kids I think it's
like better it's easier however
I do think that if a man can swing a
girl with no kids I would tell him to go
pick the girls no kids because my um my
dad my mom with my two brothers and he
already had my sister before I am the
only child from my mom
and I mean they took it over 30 years
it's one of the best relationships I've
ever seen yeah they both had children
before they met each other and that's it
right isn't it sometimes that you know
in the day in the day and age that we
live in sometimes connection is is more
important because to find someone that
you actually truly connect with and you
have any type of
anything with you've got to take that
regardless of their past regardless of
whatever you take that yeah I don't
think connection overrides what's easier
and better for a family again I'm not
saying you can't date someone with kids
I'm saying like why would you pick
someone with a kid when you could pick
someone without a kid yeah yeah of
course if you have that option yeah of
course I understand yeah but at the same
time it depends on the situation like
for you know if you're um I couldn't
speak for a man I'm a man so you know me
as a man that I have kids you know
I would feel more not like more
comfortable but if a woman has kids it
will make my life a lot easier on feet
knowing that she understands the
experience she understands the pros and
cons she understands the headache
whereas a woman that hasn't has kids
would be like why do I need to put up
with that yeah I don't need that and a
lot of women will show that emotion and
it and it's a big tone on a man's life
what if she was motherly though what if
she liked your kids and she was that's
no problem I'm not ruling that out yeah
I'm not ruling it out I'm just saying
there's a potential chance that a woman
that has no kids she would be like well
you know I'm not kids it won't be and it
might put her off even having one yeah
yeah you know yeah
I mean I'm not I'm I'm just saying if
you got two girls exactly the same one
with child one without a child
I don't know why you wouldn't pick no
child yeah they're exactly the same
they're exactly the same way
I don't agree to you have your own child
though as well because I wanna
over time like also wouldn't you be more
empathetic if we're classing it as a
mistake if you've made a mistake I don't
really think we should be calling USA
anyway but if we are you should be more
empathetic towards the other person you
shouldn't judge someone else for making
it well again I do judge the women a
little more because again again to make
that mistake they had all these choices
remember we broke that down earlier the
man didn't have all these choices and
usually the woman leaves so I do judge
the women a bit more than the men
because if they both make the first bad
choice right the man doesn't really get
a say after that and especially if she
leaves then like what is he supposed to
do he can't make her can I ask you a
question so say you had a little sister
then
a kid or two kids
what would you say about that I would
say they got no kids
no I would say don't do that that's not
a good idea what if you know he treats
her the best and like you know at the
end of the day you can't look at
someone's situations it's like looking
at someone's criminal record or
someone's past or someone's you know you
go look at the current position of how
they are and know how to treat that
person I really do think you should look
at like if if he had a criminal record I
would also say don't date him yeah but
so I do I do think you should look at
that
um I do think you should look at his
past but that doesn't Define the person
I think that the best predictor of
future behavior is past Behavior so if
you did something for five years you're
probably gonna do it in the future but
somebody's gonna obviously have to get
involved no no real children I feel like
people in the future like you said
people change people grow people reform
people you know people change their
lives you know we're not the same people
we were last week yesterday probably a
minute ago so we've got a look forward
one time I was dating this guy my dad
was not a fan of you and I said to my
dad I said Dad
you know do people change he knew I was
talking about him right and my dad looks
at me and he goes yeah they do change
they get worse over time so whatever
trait you see now just expect it to get
worse in 10 years that's not true if you
commit a crime when you're a teenager
that doesn't mean you know we could talk
about these exceptions right you know
but like over time
I I think people kind of have a core of
who they are are you saying like once a
cheat or always a cheater kind of thing
or one so whatever always that I think
that if you date someone that's cheated
in the past he's more likely to cheat
than someone who has not cheated in the
past
so I do think that yeah you should look
at people's pasts
I feel like it doesn't necessarily
Define somebody 100 though because a lot
of these traumas a lot of these
situations that people gone through
they've learned that they've learned to
grow from that to become the people they
are today so I kind of disagree I'm
completely depends on your circumstances
exactly class and what you're born into
like you could be a good person but
you've been bored it's Wolverine you
know I think that um and people will say
you know Pearl you didn't grow up with
in that situation so maybe you shouldn't
have an opinion but I do have an opinion
so I'm gonna say it
um I think that you know my dad grew up
pretty poor and he wouldn't do that
because he's not the type of guy I just
think you're either that type of person
that will do that or you aren't there's
so many factors that contribute like
your dad might have had a protective
factor I don't know what it might be but
he might have that other people didn't
have like there's so many dependencies
he may not have seen his mom getting
beaten he may not have suffered domestic
disease he may have he might not have
had an older Mentor we've come up with a
lot of extreme situations today with a
lot of like every extreme we've come up
with I mean it depends on what warp of
life you know you've been around
I grew up in um I grew up in Trinidad
it's not the
the best place when it comes to Crime I
grew up like literally a wrong violence
and I was around it now I could have
made a choice to be in it
or stay out of it
now not because I was in it means I was
going to become that person
so I I just believe that at the end of
the day it's like it all boils down the
choice and it's nothing deep
you choose to be an edge you choose to
be out of it exactly
that's also discrimination in a sense as
well so he's agreeing with me there's
also choices there's also factors like
ADHD which is a risk factor like if that
means you're more of a risk taker that
means it's harder for you to focus that
means it's hard for you to see the
future that's much deeper don't worry
what I'm hearing is excuses
I go to court imagine I go to court okay
your honor I'm sorry I committed this
crime I have ADHD
everybody in themselves want to be
better right no matter what situation
you want the best outcome of easy
tuition
the only reason you understand it is
because one delusional to
oh whatever it is but because you want
to be better now you have that choice
either you stay or you don't that's not
even discrimination that's just this is
up to what you personally want but
imagine yourself
exactly I think I think if you guys were
asking if I would want my sister to date
someone with a criminal record I think
that's how we got into this I think and
I'm gonna stand on that I would say
don't date the guy with the criminal
records
what started with the kids and then he
said that's like judging someone on
their criminal record and I said I would
in fact judge someone on their criminal
record I I would say I would judge
people based on their choices that they
make
um I think that's a fair statement but
some people are born into situations
where they're they're more they're at an
advantage to make better choices yeah
but you said age sorry ADHD before on
trauma like yeah you have it yes but
that does not mean that you should stay
in it
your brain literally sends you different
signals to make different decisions it's
a big factor a big factor doesn't change
your goals and dreams of what you want
to become yeah but a lot of people
yeah it changes the way that you react
to certain situations how you deal with
how you how you process information
that's a big factor I really think
that's just an excuse it's not an excuse
I think it's not an excuse I mean I I
have ADHD yes
I committed no crimes no crimes no crime
but we're not for example we are not
black males born in well I didn't have
loose money but not proper poverty
probably and not with the same pressure
and not with the same for example in
London people born in poverty live next
to people who have so much money social
media shows people so much money so have
you ever seen real poverty uh yeah I
have I do a lot of a lot of volunteers
yeah
so I just think like poverty here isn't
really real poverty I went to India one
time
that's real poverty I have never seen
more homeless people I'm hungry yeah and
was like during this like super hot
summer like people were dying on the
street it was really sad it's not nice
it's not just about people it's about
the entities and what they've been
they've been through and all
so some of them are ex not obviously
we're not saying everyone born into
crime is black but some of them are and
they experience racism as well they have
a lot to prove like it's very hard as a
teenage boy to feel that you're in
poverty you don't have
lack of opportunity yeah you don't feel
secure and you're trying to prove
yourself and it's very hard as a
teenager not to try and be cool and
unfortunately in London now to be cool
and to be worthy and to feel good or fit
in so you're a bad boy and girls also
women actually are a problem in this
because teenage girls go for that and
that actually encourages them so much
perception so what does it take
um from a successful man who was in
poverty to become successful
I think there must there's a problem
they went really trauma they went
through this they went through that
everybody's different some people do
have a stronger mindset than others and
that's okay but it's also possible for
anybody that's that's just my opinion
there are put many possibilities for
everybody like you can do whatever you
put your mind to but there are some
situations where
life in general is heavy and they don't
have the brain capacity to even think
about next week
no I'm talking about like these are
brain capacity yeah in regards to
dealing with everything
um like work stress family stress
struggle stress money stress people who
came out of that though that's what I'm
saying but yeah but you don't know what
those people have had different like
what if you're more rebellious because
you don't have attachments to your
parents
how are people in the same exact family
where one grew up to be a
multi-millionaire and one group to be an
alcoholic it's choices like I'm just not
with this this excuse that excuse that
excuse I know people in countries that
have real poverty that have real like no
options and so it's like you're spoiled
we sound in the west to say on my ADHD
oh yes you know what you know as well
right yeah exactly India wherever you
you know whichever country you were
given the example that is what they know
we don't know so we can't we only can't
you can't compare them okay I grew up
with like nannies from around the world
so like we had a different Nanny from
like a different country every year so
I've spoken to people from literally
like I grew up with them all over the
world and I'm telling you like the we
sound so spoiled I agree with you to
expect because I've also seen I've also
seen poverty like that but unless we
take all of our children and teenagers
to developing countries and show them
they like you said they only know
they're only in that world so if you're
fortunate to have a nanny there's
certain Lifestyles can't even comprehend
because there are certain people that
can't even afford to eat so there's I
can comprehend this is the Holo you're
rich you know they're for choices it
still goes back to you can still be born
into anything in your choices uh it
still matters and it's who you are
absolutely so I I don't really know like
what we're arguing here like you should
be given a pass because you grew up in a
bad situation
we're going off topic a little bit Yeah
because we're talking about people's
Lifestyles and people's backgrounds that
doesn't Define you as a person and for
me these experiences make you know they
can build cars it builds it builds
character builds somebody it builds you
from from nothing to something and if
you if you're gonna shut the door on
potentially the love of your life or
somebody that's good for you just
because of you what have you done
yesterday or before he met you then
you're living in a delusional world
because I'm saying what you know and
depending on how you've been brought up
and where you're from your your the
people that you've been around your
where your parents or your family
otherwise it is relevant and you only
know what I think it's actually really
smart to look at people's background
when dating it is a certain aspect it is
it is I'm not saying can't overcome bad
choices some people do but I still do
think that if a guy has a criminal
background you should maybe choose a guy
that doesn't be more precautious for
sure you know I think it depends on what
criminal background they have though
because he can't be you can't look at us
oh he's got a criminal record he is you
know he's a bad guy or it depends what
it is and what skills obviously all of
this really goes back to the women I
gotta be honest
because because it's like
these guys or girls or whatever come
from these bad backgrounds right but why
do they come from these bad backgrounds
well the women destroyed the home most
of them yeah yeah the women
um either chose to have children with
men that weren't fathers
um nor wanted to be fathers
or they chose um to leave their husband
or their boyfriend whatever it is and
then we're going back to the kids
suffering right right and now they're in
this traumatic situation with like where
they maybe make bad decisions so really
this is like full circle guys you know
it's a vicious cycle can I just ask you
that because you said it's better to
have children young but actually you're
more likely to make mistakes at that age
and have children with the wrong
question and then you exacerbate cycle
what are you like what do you mean
you're more likely to make mistakes
because you're younger you're not as
you're not as well you're not as
experienced like I want to make sure I
am picking the right person that's why
some people I've dated in the past I
would not have a child
I think that
um you really just you'll never know for
sure I think like because what what are
you gonna find out
like you're never really gonna know till
you get married or till you live with
someone so it's like I feel like women
like we operate in fear like oh like we
could find someone better oh something
could go wrong where it's like you just
pick someone and for security make it
works this is something I always say
yeah I think currently we know too much
when it comes to life Society society
and choices and
because of that every time we're trying
to make a decision we always have
excuses
every single time the thing is though
it's facts that some people are born
into harder circumstances than others so
how how is that an excuse
yeah but it's it's not that full that's
why I always go back to our grandparents
one day one day our grandparents and our
parents and our great grandparents what
made them stay together Amazing by the
way knowing that they probably went to
the same dramas same experiences seem
everything like they probably had it
worse honestly they probably had to
present us but like what made them stay
that's why we have things like
intergenerational trauma it's no
original traumas trauma passed down
because of people in the past didn't
have access to mental health they didn't
understand it I think people all had
generational trauma they lived through
like famines and [__] yeah a lot a lot
you know a lot of people yeah back in
the day they were told to shut up and
sit down and get on with you but not
everywhere there's a lot of trauma now
but not everybody's born in in like um
the women may I think no I think the
world might be better if we did no no
but back in the day like for both men
and women you wouldn't necessarily
Express especially men I mean men have
got it that's a whole nother topic men
have got it extremely hard
um but
it's only more recent days that it's you
know mental health and access to
treatment and stuff has come to light
like over the last like kind of what
five years ish I don't know if that's
right or not I think that mental health
makes us crazier
yeah yeah I think that mental health is
actually I think psychologists or
whatever make people crazy and don't fix
them and actually make the problem worse
why what do you mean in terms of like so
the last 20 years have we had an
increase in therapy or a decrease in
there increase increase so in the last
20 years have we had an increase in
mental health problems increase so
that's working most people are aware
they could and they're comfortable to
seek help and back in the day there was
a massive stigma so I you know what I
think about therapy I think we were
actually so the average woman used to
have five kids right and I think you
were meant to talk about your problems
with your family and your siblings but
now we're in this Society where women
didn't have multiple kids they were in
single parent homes and now we have no
one to talk to no one that we feel close
with and so I think it was meant to be
your family and now you're talking to a
stranger which I'm in the psychology
program actually at my school and I
can't tell you these women in the
program dear God don't go to them dear
God they're nuts they're all they're all
freaking crazy I I see I see the behind
the scenes who you guys are going with
the psychologists are yeah yeah because
they're all trying to be therapists
right yeah and they're always the
craziest women they're like dear God I
hope you don't fix my mental health they
probably have a passion for it because
of that and it actually can make them
more relatable not all of them of course
there's some that wouldn't be but then
but then it's like so we have to look at
are they fixing the problem well if the
problem's getting worse I can't say
they're fixing it a lot the problem is
getting worse because not worse it the
statistics are worse because more people
are coming forward and actually seeking
help because it's okay and also talk
about how social media is actually
making yeah 100 can I say one more thing
you can't always speak to your family
most the time you people who experience
trauma it's from their family so you
would never be asked to talk to your
family you may be embarrassed yeah and
also they could Gaslight you they can
make you think that it's not real like
you can't go
yeah so I'll go so that's why you're
supposed to have fi like they're
supposed to have like five kids because
you'd imagine one of your siblings would
understand they've been through the same
thing yeah that you can get comfortable
and then number two number two that's
the other thing the therapists you you
kind of you'll see your family will
Gaslight you well maybe you are
overreacting maybe you don't have trauma
and the therapist is paid to tell you
you have trauma so you'll come back
people people that's true when people
are suffering
severe mental health issues they can
feel so bad like it's obvious that it's
real no one wants to feel bad like no
one wants to be if they had the choice
they wouldn't be in that okay so I'll
give you I'll give you one I do think
there is severe Trauma from men that
come back from war not you getting get
cheated on by your ex-boyfriend Becky
but that's a good point most people that
get cheated on and then it affects them
so much they they've already got
abandonment and trust issues from things
that stem from their family people
people that are very secure and don't
have that trauma they can accept that I
think you should just get over it I
think we should just get over stuff yeah
I think there's real problems like I
think if you were graped that's real
trauma I think if you went to like War
yeah but you know you fight him with
your mother is that real you should just
get over it it depends on why you're
fighting it depends on so many things it
depends on if you've had an
unpredictable environmentally started I
would say like abuse
um but there's a lot of abuse there's
mental health you know you can't just
say me grabbing you and being physical
is abuse mental abuses is a lot more
harmful than physical abuse I do think
if you were mentally if you were real
mentally abused I think that a lot of
times we add in all these things that
are mental abuse that aren't really
mental abuse but if you are seriously
mentally abused I'll give you that yeah
and I also think I agree one tiny bit
with you in that
people don't have actually and the words
are thrown about a bit too much if
you're not really clinically anxious not
clinically depressed we can't be like oh
we're having a down day I'm depressed
I'm a bit nervous I'm excuses because
actually they are that invalidates that
invalidation
sometimes the people that are suffering
for real yeah some people are really
suffering with that and then everyone's
throwing the word around it's like no
you don't actually understand yeah it's
true that's true I do agree that's true
sometimes it's excuses it's just you
know trying to make something very much
I think okay because imagine right your
sister is telling you about a problem
you're gonna have a completely different
reaction because you know your sister so
if your sister says this person reacted
to me this way well you know your
sister's a [__] so of course
damn but the therapist is gonna say ah
you poor thing you were not the problem
but the family knows how the person is
now I'm not saying take advice from
every family member certainly not your
mother that you know maybe is a bit
crazy broke the whole family up don't
ask advice from her but maybe your
father right the men are a little more
logical they're trying to fix problems
yeah um my therapist will also make you
go deeper into whatever that is like how
do you interpret yeah yeah the therapist
especially if they're women they don't
want to fix it they just want to talk
about how it made you feel yeah we
should be looking to fix the problem
what would solve this obviously they are
meant to do that also as well as being
empathetic they should be something
called developing discrepancy and
cognitive dissonance which is saying
like for example you're saying this on
one hand you're saying that on the other
hand and you are meant to make people
think twice as well as being I went to
therapy once yeah they didn't like me
there
I was just like this is the dumbest
thing I've ever well what like why
because she wasn't trying to fix my
problems she was just like asking and
I'm like they're trying to keep you in
your problems yeah yeah that's what it
is I was like trying to make you
questions so yeah yeah try to ask me
about my childhood I'm like what do you
need to know about my child where did it
start from what does that have to do
with where
they trick you into thinking you had
trauma I think that if you okay there
was a girl that came from North Korea
all right this woman had the craziest
story she freaking was graped she had
she was running from like it was a very
very sad story and she was so confused
because when she got to America like all
these women were going to therapy over
their ex-boyfriends and she's like I
escaped North Korea I'm I don't need
therapy and she thought the idea of
therapy was so dumb this is a woman that
was literally
it has was escaping like communism I
feel like some people have a different
mindset like if you really like strong
mentally you can overcome a lot of more
things it's a lot of people that you
know no disrespect but are quite weak
mentality that mentally tend to suffer a
lot more like when it comes to things
that happen to them and they kind of
just suppress it into mental like
certain health and whatever like you
know I'm I I I've gone through a lot of
things that I've actually thought to
myself is it excuses or am I really
going through something or you know like
it plays tricks on you as well because
you feel offended or you feel like oh
I'm having a bad day I'm having a a bad
run of days and you know sometimes it's
just the storm over your head that's
going to pass and you just gotta make
sure that you know in your head that
there's a lot at the end of that tunnel
you know what I'm saying so for sure but
sometimes it's not it's not as easy and
just because somebody has gone through
something more than what you have
doesn't just discredit what you're going
on those people are lucky I think it
does discredit it doesn't it
well then I was super traumatized with
my nanny
um you know I I could say you know one
time my dad went on a business trip and
I didn't get to see him boohoo I'm so
traumatized don't discredit me that's
not true no no it's trauma I'm trauma
but that but but she's right though in a
way because that's her trauma you can't
really question it in a way that's okay
my point is I I can't let it affect you
that would depend on so many things
whether your dad was never there how
many times did this happen to you like
how strong was your attachment with your
mom like there's so many dependencies to
that and also resilience is built by the
age of seven so your first seven years
are very important like not taking away
from anyone that's had serious trauma
but they may be more resilient if their
first time women shouldn't leave because
they need the mom and the day it's like
she's on my team now do you know where
it is
I feel like what you're saying yeah in
in what I'm getting is the woman is the
core
I feel like the woman's the core to the
family and that's real but the reason
why I say that because
when a woman goes
like nine times out of ten I mean I've
I've witnessed it myself there's the
family bond is gone it's uh you know
disappeared or was it's um you know
scattered you know the woman holds the
the woman is the home I feel the home
the foundation the family the you know
the you know you know what I'm saying
like so everybody have their different
opinions but I wouldn't say that it's
always the woman's fault you know what
I'm saying I wouldn't say that that's
that's equal
say it again I post anything that's
equal well as in the man also is yeah of
course but in a way who's taking that
who takes care of the kids more you know
like in a way it's a different way
there's a different way of how like your
mom for example takes care of you
differently how your dad does yeah and
you see your mom and you you know you
love both your parents but you love your
mom and your dad differently in a way
not in a way you love your mom more than
your dad or whatever but there's a
different Comfort but that's good you
know what I'm saying Party play their
part of course but at the same time
there's research to show like the
primary if the pro if there's a break in
the attachment with the primary
caregiver which can be a mum or a dad
but usually is a mum
um that can affect life
um chances for the rest of your life so
you're more likely to go to prison
you're less likely to do well isn't that
the dad no it's it's either so a PR also
it could be both a primary single
attachment figure and also that doesn't
have to just be you don't see them for a
couple of months that can be their
unpredictable that can be their
suffering from mental health issues that
isn't a break in an attachment I will
say single father homes have better
outcomes than single mother homes yeah
statistically yeah
single father homes have better outcomes
than single mother home but then that's
when I disagree because no it's not it's
not like a disagreement like there's no
other Home kids like go to jail more
they feel out of school awful that was
this I thought oh okay okay single
mothers okay okay kids are with a single
mom okay yeah
yeah with a single dad they fail out of
school at last I mean it's still not
great you know we we would like them
together yeah yeah of course yeah I'm
gonna Read Super chats for a second and
then blessing we're gonna react to one
more thing you know just talk about this
crap so glad we all get along and I'll
say one more thing about being weak
that's very unfair because people are
suffering mental health issues they have
to fight battles every single day and
people don't understand they're Stronger
Yeah check in on your friends yeah
um
I think there's real mental health and
there's fake mental health and I I
totally agree with that um we can't be
the ones judging that though you just
gotta look at it as I will do it yeah
I I could I couldn't judge it because
you don't really know you know what I'm
saying you can't I think I think that
you know you kind of do know which
friends are kind of just being dramatic
and which friends are acting this is why
but then but then this is why a lot of
people that do suffer with it turn to
the people that you or also whoever
whoever that think oh you're just faking
it all this is an excuse this is why I
encourage it doesn't help them in a way
where they're going through something
they want to go to the closest people
that they have but you're like oh it's
not that deep though is it like you
can't think like that yeah you gotta
think you know more time I get help from
people that I don't know I get help from
strangers I don't know because people
that don't know me from the past they'll
look at my situation right now and be
like you know what let me help you get
through that whereas the people that I
know will look at oh well I know how you
like how you like and what you've been
like I don't really believe that because
the traits or the characteristics that
I've LED them to think that oh I'm
faking it whereas we should look at the
moment yeah why do you think like that
not be that harmful you know get over it
I don't get why would they think you're
faking it because they're looking at you
because exactly because they look
they're looking at how you are so they
may point out little things that they
think oh you're maybe too gullible or
maybe you're too sensitive or you're
being dramatic or whatever but what did
you go through but that doesn't matter a
dog that shouldn't matter right now I
feel like this right now I'm happy right
now I'm upset why should I why should
you shouldn't let your emotions control
you though no but at the same time at
the same time we're human and and that's
that's part of of being a being you know
what I'm saying some people have seen
Role Models they're parents that can
manage emotions some people haven't been
beaten up but but I will be little okay
okay let me let me so they can manage
that emotions
okay okay we could say but all right but
wherever we're starting we could start
here we start here shouldn't the goal be
to manage your emotion 100 but that's
why people should go to therapy and they
should admit it but I'm saying like like
if everyone in your life is telling you
you're dramatic you don't think maybe
you're dramatic not really because like
I said if you're reaching out to
somebody anything could be somewhere you
know it doesn't have to be a therapist
yeah so but like I'm saying if you're
reaching us to somebody you're having
the like probably one percent confidence
to think oh let me tell somebody how I
feel you might be embarrassed you might
feel you know that that much trauma that
you don't wanna you don't want to open
up like a lot of men don't speak about
certain things do you know what I'm
saying why is there more men that kill
themselves yeah than women do because a
lot of men keep it in their heads I've
been that man I've been that man right
I've been that man so for me it's like
okay I'm gonna tell you how I feel but
you're gonna be like I'll be a man yeah
be a manifier you know what I'm saying
that you're brushing it you're brushing
it because you're in a better place than
I am so I should be in at your level but
you're not at my level so respect that
man just respect my perception or how I
view things because I view life and I
walk live completely different than how
you do exactly you should get it so I
can't I can't judge somebody and be like
oh you know your problems and greater
than mine everybody's problems are
greater than you know nobody's problem
is greater than anybody else's you know
what I'm saying my whole point is we
should be looking to like solve the
problem exactly but we're brushing it
off like it's not a problem
therapy and medication and mindfulness
and all these things that we guided
towards there is no there is evidence
there is statistics that do show that it
works especially if you combine them I
meant like when I last looked at
assistance which was a while ago for
example therapy was a third gave you a
30 of chance of getting better
medication gave you a 30 chance of
getting better together they gave you a
60 chance so there is evidence otherwise
they wouldn't yeah a lot of these things
no here's the problem a lot of these
studies are funded by these like
feminists yeah it's like these women in
the gender studies program
yeah I just about what men feeling more
than women like yeah they're not not I
think they're meds that's the only thing
I disagree with can I be wrong I think I
think it's kind of equal I think women
do suffer with a lot of trauma mental
health as well you've got to look at it
because you know like you said look a
single mother with a lot of kids that's
been cheated on or left by the husband
or whatever like definition of women's
oh yeah
oh yeah trauma comes from choices yeah
but so does men though everybody goes
Olympics it's like it's like victim
victims like I just feel like it's a
mentality do you know not everyone's
born of a silver spoon yeah you know
what I'm saying let's be real some
people are born provide all of these
opportunities that some people do you
know what I'm saying I know people born
with zero opportunities that made
something out of them that didn't look
at themselves as a victim that doesn't
mean they didn't have mental health that
might be the insecurity and Trauma that
drove them to prove themselves they
might not actually be happy a lot if you
keep it all in it actually leads to
there's evidence physical health issues
as well and also what he was going to
say about people oh yeah I know a lot of
people especially older people even
relatives the ones that are in denial
one can't admit it because of the shame
they just spiraled down a lot of the
time they end up in suicide or just very
severe mental health
day I think um
we do know that at the end of this
conversation is that each and every
person can improve 100 now how to
improve is what they need to be aware of
and as long as you bring that awareness
to them then they have a choice to get
better yeah for sure and also just
because you have a problem doesn't
necessarily mean you're making yourself
a victim you're not labeling yourself as
a victim it's other people that are
saying that you are saying I think I
think that you are if you're constantly
talking about your problem but then if
you're dealing with it if every time
someone like if you're always bringing
up your problem again and again this is
why I wanted to bring up the topic of
social media because that's where people
put their problems but not necessarily
because if you're constantly bringing
your problems maybe listen Maybe sit
down and be like okay what is the root
of your problem maybe he's crying out
for help and then guess what that same
person might have killed himself you'd
be like do you know I wish I I wish I
listened oh I wish I was there for that
person you know people want to give you
the flowers when you're dead and buried
but they don't want to give you flowers
when you're alive and I just feel like
people are really like you know
delusional in a sense where they don't
listen to the people that are talking
about this from like an individualistic
point of view so it's like if you have a
problem and it's like if you're
constantly talking about your problem
and talking about your problem it's not
gonna make it better it's a solution and
I'm not I'm not saying you can't talk to
anyone about your problem ever but this
idea like you want to go to everyone
talk about your problem forever talk
about your problem to a therapist is it
gonna fix it no they need to take active
steps which is therapy which is
meditation which is sometimes medication
whether you agree with or not there's
lots of different things you can
obviously they should improve I don't I
don't really think it's great if someone
just sits in it and doesn't do any of
the steps but the problem is if they
listen to some things that you say pal
they won't even start that process and
that's the issue with with
um I I say I say you should get over
stuff yeah
I think that mentality is is it's good
for me it's selfish because I feel like
people just live for themselves people
think for themselves oh I disagree
it's not selfish because you get over it
for everyone around you nobody no but
someone you're here to talk about your
problems all the time yeah but if you
get over it and then you're a happy
person and then you're done talking
about your problems all the time you do
know that like so neural Pathways how
our brain works for your problems the
patterns of how we think guys and how we
manage our emotions they are actually
built neural Pathways when we are
younger it's not that easy to snap out
of there you can improve it you can
encourage alternative thoughts but it
takes a while you're building new habits
and you can see that in the brain your
neural Pathways have to change that's
the fact I like that yeah so so it is
more difficult for other people I
understand it's more difficult for some
people but I think that the point is
still the same why would you want to
talk about your problems all the time I
don't think that's what
therapy could be anything exactly I
don't think we should come to me it's a
problem and I could just simply give you
a book and that's your therapy I mean I
understand if you're saying someone's
always talking about their problems all
the time you may look at it as an excuse
but at the same time maybe find out the
root of why they're always talking about
their problems because instead of
dismissing it and thinking right
questions maybe you know help that
person and if that help that you've
extended doesn't reach them then you can
say well get over it in a way and
respectfully but I I don't know talking
about this from an individual
point of view like you have the problem
I'm like I I was trying to get over it
and so yeah but that's their problem so
if they're reaching their hand you know
like you know they if they reach in the
hand they have that confidence to to to
to feel trust or or some sort of you
know comfort in in disclosing a private
you know trauma that they're going
through in hopes that maybe you can help
them I don't know guys I'll listen and
I'll be like all right how can we solve
this problem 100 yeah I mean that's the
right step but my question my question
is still like if you're going around
talking to people about your problems
and everyone's saying something to you
like I don't know why you wouldn't think
it says something about you
if it's like five different people
telling you the same thing it might mean
something that's all upset why is that
but if they are um demonstrating traits
on my mom and I say hey Mom this is my
problem then I go to my sister and she
says the same thing and then I go to my
brother and he says the same thing and I
go my other I got a lot of siblings and
they all tell me the same thing like
wouldn't that mean something maybe all
of you guys that have heard the problem
should all come together maybe resolve a
solution maybe you have unhealthy ways
of coping or unhelpful personality
traits because of your trauma and that's
why it has to be addressed you're tired
of the word trauma I feel like trauma's
War
every day is a war everybody goes
through Wars in different situations
every day is a war in different
situations different circumstances not
like that statement the thing is Paul
they have actually passed on that trauma
there is a thing called
intergenerational trauma it's passed on
slightly through genetics or the outside
of DNA basically can slightly change but
also through the way they parent you and
don't attached you properly and have
emotional outbursts have PTSD that's
very hard for a child I feel like this
is a lot of like word salad okay just
saying you know
I still stand by trauma War abuse yeah
it gets passed on it's not worth it it's
facts and it can be studied I didn't
know that it does yeah of course but you
said dna-wise DNA no no but it gets
passed down by like maybe experience so
no idea
so there's evidence I can't I don't know
how to get exactly right it's not the
actual genes but it's something about
the myelation or the outside of the DNA
can slightly can slightly change
so like for example
um
people like in Black Culture people that
have experienced slavery and also the
the the
um the division of families for example
there because it was hard to keep a
family that gets passed down is actually
hard of some people I think the biggest
trauma
is really women breaking up the family
[Laughter]
I'm gonna read the super chats guys
remember blessing is so mean he said
only over 20 bucks so
um I know he's a big needy over there
Dan the therapist the rate of divorce
for a couple with both having children
from previous marriage is 70 percent
yeah so if you both have kids 70 chance
of divorce see 45 success
no no no no no it's the divorce so
you're if you both have children
um 70 chance of divorce 45 of people who
cheat do it again compared to 18 who
have not done it before so
Matt thank you Dan the therapist
Lawrence Bullock getting with a woman
with kids you're assuming the kids will
accept you as a father figure the
majority of the kids do not uh thank you
uh Lawrence Bullock what a nice guy
um I think that's all of them right now
so next we're gonna react to one more
thing we've had a very you know I I kind
of thought we'd get through some more
um but but it's okay we'll have one more
before we close out the show all right
foreign
now my question is why does this woman
exist like why does this level of
delusion exist go on all right go ahead
um
is it not going
she's going viral on Twitter right now
oh let's hear this
here we go
we gotta make sure the sounds up on the
video
on the computer is it on
okay
do you ever get dressed and just be like
damn I look good
do you ever get dressed go girl
confidence
you do your thing man
all right
I think you guys are liars no I'm not
you know why I'm not a liar let's be
real yeah I wanna sell confidence
self-love is all you need in this world
I don't care what you don't think I
don't care
I want to hear answers from you first
before I answer this question go on no
no okay oh I I think that
um you're a liar I think you're a big
liar yep
um and the reason I think that is
because you know damn well she don't
look good you know damn well you would
not wife her you know damn well you you
probably wouldn't even sleep sorry it's
not about the look at all she's at a
very high risk of our health conditions
right now high risk of being obese yeah
but who cares she loves herself and
that's true that matters which is
understood but do you love yourself by
killing yourself some people do and that
doesn't matter that's that's your life
if you want to choose to you live your
life but you live your life that's up to
you my friends
I would say I would say liar okay South
I think one it's selfish to be fat
everybody's gotta look at you
no serious I'm sorry
let me finish okay because one she goes
in an airplane what happens every the
Flubber goes over the scene
she should have to but a lot of times I
have I I had a friend that went viral
actually because she was stuck between
two fat people who wanted two seats what
is that the one who requested two seats
from the airline I I don't know if she I
don't know if she ended up doing that it
was Sydney Watson I did like a vice
panel with her she went viral yeah yeah
yeah because she because the blubber and
then on top top of that if you make
those choices someone's got to take care
of you so if she is fat either the
Health Care system so all you're making
the nurses all take care but sometimes
the health conditions
is a health condition okay can we all
right I just need I need for this
conversation for us not to talk about
exceptions let's talk about the rule the
average person's fat because they eat
too much would you personal trainer
would you agree with that 100 okay so I
used to be a personal trainer okay so I
can also elaborate on that all right we
could we could not understand what
you're saying I just feel like for me
yeah like a lot of the times like it's
health conditions as well because
obesity you know and there's certain
health conditions that that allow you to
to put on weight or certain medications
you may be on medication or something
and I'm a lot you know makes you put on
weight on unfortunately it's not your
food doesn't mean you're eating all day
like just be real that much weight but
do you know her situation but do we know
her situation can we can we do again
we're trying to talk about the rule
we're gonna go back and forth all day if
we say but that accepts it's very it's a
bit frustrating sir I had a question
actually because when we're doing the
delusion a lot of people excluded
obesity so I don't know
doesn't necessarily mean I'm I'm fit to
sit here and judge someone's lifestyle
decisions but that's like exactly that's
like why would you want to be with
someone obese because it's not my
preference I don't I personally don't
find that attractive okay
then why are you supporting it I'm not
support I'm not supporting it but I'm
definitely no you're not supporting it
sit here and be rude say mean comments
for the sake of it like if she has
self-love and confidence for that's
crazy that's an inspiration confidence
exactly that's an inspiration that's
what I'm rating it's not an insult it's
not delusion it's not well
I don't think the topic is about how
confidence or her emotional topic was
about her weight but has nothing to do
with me okay
she gets that way but yeah how can I
judge her if she doesn't mind
system is is a point yeah I think it's
selfish to be that fat but what is your
question is what I want to know my
question is why do we allow women to
live in this level of delusion where we
parade them on social media for being
chronically obese and clearly like if a
girl was anorexic and she she came
forward and said oh I look so good today
we would say no that's not healthy but
when an obese woman does it you guys
cheer it on back in the day though like
a lot of the supermarkets we're not
talking about back in the day we're
talking about now all right so I think
personally
um
you know we live in this world now where
a lot of things are accepted without our
control and for me yourself yeah I'll
control myself right but we're not
talking about if I'm attracted or not
I'm looking at a video of a person that
is extremely happy with herself and as
as actually looking at herself and
thinking I look good and so you should
feel that way because I'm not gonna
accept uh from anybody telling me I'm a
fat piece of [__] oh I'm this or not
because then in the day that's your
opinion yeah but I am as good as I feel
and that's how it is opinion to say that
you need to lose weight it's not good
for your health yeah but that's her
choices
her choices affect everybody else and it
also it also shows like what we see in
the media like why are we pushing fat
women as models why are we pushing fat
women because of magazines no no because
we shouldn't be pushing that in a
society we should like do you care it
depends
yeah but she was obese and you guys
cheered it on like that that is
it wasn't the weight that we were
cheering on it was it was the confidence
and the self-love that she had
regardless of her sister that's like
that's narcissism
obesity is an actual problem
it is a problem I said it could be
underlying health issues I said that and
if according to what she said if we
support people like that that we only uh
sorry encouraging them to maintain the
way they are
and that Holyfield no but yeah they are
but you can't help certain people that
gain that weight like I said it could be
x amount of reasons why but no no no no
but what I'm saying so you know some
people take medications that make him
put on weight you know some steroids no
not just steroids just the other things
I don't know but I'm saying okay so
you're speaking on something you don't
even know okay fair enough but I'm
saying I'm saying but it's not just
eating I know someone with no thyroid
that's in tape she literally doesn't
have one
no no but I'm asking you you don't even
know so I'm asking you what name them
name the medication I'm not a doctor I
can't name the medication it could be a
backlash to that era where supermodels
were a lot of them were anorexic could
just be like we're going through that
and then it will balance out again maybe
no no no come on but I mean let's just
be real so you think people are obese
because they just eat that's my question
yes 90 or 95 yes is a bad diet choice
okay 95 others is uh health conditions
where you know you this is there isn't
involved because of the health condition
I guess steroid scores than the game of
it or eat more
the last time I researched it was the
minority that I had tough yeah actually
and I have a question you said um you're
only as good as you feel but aren't you
only as good as you are
but that's that's that but this is what
I'm saying because like otherwise it's
delusional so if I go around wait wait
so if I go around and I say I'm a
millionaire oh I'm A Millionaire I'm a
millionaire I'm a millionaire but I have
zero dollars in my bank account how am I
not delusional but women will go around
saying I'm beautiful I look great this
this and this when it's clearly not true
everyone in this room knows it's not
true everyone in the room wait wait
everyone in the room knows she's
delusional everyone in the room knows
that you would not want to look like her
but we cheer it on why why because
because like you gotta be happy for
someone except in who they are and if
you encouraging somebody to to be like
oh well you're fat you're undesirable
what are you doing today
it's all about you wait wait so it's all
about you as a person so I I've been
pretty overweight I was over 200 pounds
at one point and literally do you know
what made me switch was all the guys
laughing at work how they wouldn't date
a girl over 200 pounds and I was like oh
my God that's their opinion no no no but
I was good I was so glad I heard that
because I made a change but everybody
lying that's why I said liars and
cheering her on it's like you're not
telling them the truth and sometimes the
truth hurts but you make better
decisions because of it I just want to
say something fast like sorry um
so because it happened to my mom quad
forbid she has to go to the oh well
because it happened to my mom you have
to go to the doctor and see the doctor I
need doctors like you're in such a
high-risk health condition that you have
to lose weight now would that person
feel good that they was being supported
by all these people telling them that be
confident love yourself continue
doing what you're doing maintain your
weight feel the way you're supposed to
feel because that's your choice
love yourself
I think it's important that they are
also informed and educated I guess the
government tries to do that and also if
we're if we're comparing it to anorexia
which is an eating disorder which is
linked to mental health is being obese
not the same thing it's an eating
disorder which is mental health which is
something that is the serious matter is
actually a habit that's something the
nobody can help apart from that person
like because if that person has a mental
health issue and on that day they decide
to get on camera and big up themselves
then guanyu because if you're going
through all of that to get to where you
are now why don't you why don't you ask
him because he's the personal trainer
but like so so are you a mental health
coach as well are you an expert right
okay so you're only topic of mental
health yeah because we compared to
anorexia anorexia is an eating disorder
which is linked to mental health so if
if obesity is also an eating disorder
which would then be linked to mental
health which means it's a mental health
condition because part of personal
training is we have to go through life
coaching um courses as well
all of that we all have mental problems
sitting here we all have mental problems
a habit
she have developed a habit which is part
of mental problems
what you do on a daily basis is a habit
do you think it's heard the tree as well
huh do you think it's something that's
passed down as well because that's
another thing because yeah it's you know
I think it goes back to the moms yeah
not teaching the kids how to eat yeah no
but some kids are born obese so how do
you how do you explain no they're
they're not no but like okay you know
what I'm saying there's some kids that
are like okay can we just okay I need to
wait wait wait so so let's let's just be
honest the mom feeds the kid so if the
kid I would go as far to say that if
your kid's obese then honestly that's
child abuse because you're putting that
kid that that's a hard life to be obese
overweight as a child sorry I wanted it
to get back to you like it's like a
smoker right every day you'd see it oh
because you you can't stop smoking you
have mental health no because no eating
disorders
eating disorder is nothing like smoking
I guess anorexic people think that they
Well normally I think or usually they
don't see their way so they actually
don't realize how skinny they are
whereas I don't know wait wait wait wait
I heard that before so you don't think
she didn't yeah
possibly possibly yes possibly
possibly but why but why are we fat
shaming though is my question is why are
we fat shaming it's like discrimination
isn't it
at all no but I feel like that is though
I I think no am I the only one that
feels that way yeah I don't think I
support every single thing that you guys
will see with her love and also her
feeling confident and everything look
I'm just praising how she feels about
herself
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
some people would find a desirable no I
support that 100 it's like pretty people
find this as I say active what I do not
support this and we cannot take this too
mental health God forbid if she is to
end up in the hospital any doctor was
like you're in a health condition at
high risk where you have to lose weight
how are you going to feel knowing that
you are supporting that person
it's not really supporting though yeah
it's you're not trying to tell them
really different aspect of it okay okay
what about people that are born like
they're faces
mental and physical is too big
difference we have to understand that
it's too big difference we're not
talking about mental we're talking about
no at the end of the days I'm supporting
how she feels about herself
we need to realize that beauty is in the
eye of the holder because everyone looks
different not everyone is born with the
same Faith okay do you okay okay I have
a question do you think you're equally
as attractive as that woman answering
the thing is it dependency
do you think that most men would find
you more attractive or her more
attractive
please please don't please just make
this please
I know you know the answer please
answer please
please yeah it's please I don't I just
don't feel comfortable even answering
something like that because you know the
answer
it's like most people probably but like
not everyone would okay but most what
did I ask most people come on we're
probably probably would find you more
attractive right
our physical state is too different I
don't support the mindset I don't think
you should be confident not that way I
think you should lose it I should think
you should be unconfident to lose it
and with that confidence she could use
that to get better yeah I believe that I
think I suppose I support that I could
use that together but but it maybe she
is and each step as as she takes she
might be on her way of losing but we
don't know that we don't know her life
we don't know but right now in this
specific moment she's happy with herself
and good for her and that's all I'm
supporting is she dropped 10 pounds we
don't know she might have been bigger
than that
you guys come up with these crazy
scenarios yeah but we're only looking at
it from how it is wait wait how much
bigger could she get who knows how much
better
who knows is what I'm saying it's like
we're supporting this and we're cheering
or on living in delusion it's delusion
yeah but the question was just hot no I
asked I asked why do we let women get to
this stage of delusion where you're
saying I look good today when you
clearly don't everybody in the room
knows she doesn't you know you wouldn't
want to switch bodies with her and it's
like I think that honestly a little bit
of bullying is good for people no it's
not I I think I've learned from bullying
that's not good for your mental health I
think it's good for strong people not
everybody is though I don't I don't
agree that I do feel like you know that
guys going through stuff can also cut
you off from your emotions you might
actually be too cough you might be hyper
independent that's actually not a good
response that's not a good response you
know I think it was a great response
when I was when I when I was indirectly
told I was fat I ran a marathon and lost
that weight babe I'm just glad that
happened but it's like it's like this
this Society it's like we can't call
spade a spade
she's fat because
we keep going back we keep going back to
mental health and as I stood your mental
and physical too big difference I think
it's important to appreciate what
different people look like because we
actually can't help it all the times yes
okay weight is a bit different thing but
like we can't judge people's appearance
all the time because sometimes it's not
someone's choice I think we should judge
people's appearances I don't think we
should judge anyone at all
only got judges man let's keep it on
that I think that you guys are liars
we have good standards but we've been
taught not to judge other people based
on their appearance
I I think that um you do judge people's
appearances every day just like you did
when we were talking about the dating
and you said you wouldn't date obese why
did you judge that's judger
different I'm not sitting here watching
um bring up a photo and saying that
person's fat haha I'm not doing that the
person
that's okay
right would you say that I am faster
because
because you know I was later
that's judging
yeah
and you're running against the fat
person of course so we are speaking on
facts and she put that picture up and
she asked that question it was a fact
that she is obese yeah
but I'm just praising her I'm praising
how she receives it I'm praising how she
sees herself and I agree and that's it
man that's and I agree with that that's
what I support that's what I think
you're praising delusion
delusion is just her loving herself if
she's paying for her own health care why
do we even care at all like it's not
about it doesn't affect it doesn't
affect us at all I know what you're
saying
I know you're doing it I know I know
what she did I know I know you did why
why do I care if she's obese
um part as a person I don't know her but
as a society I don't think we should be
promoting obesity I think that obese
people um take a toll on the Health Care
system and it's really hard on her
family like maybe if she has kids
siblings parents they're the ones that
are going to have to take care of her
therefore I think that is selfish to be
that obese if she has kids so I even if
it's parents or they're not your parents
have to watch their kid I think it's
just her choice and if she's happy with
how she is then that's fine if she's not
happy how she is then you can pass
judgment
I could be trying to help her you know
you know what I'm saying if she's happy
if she's okay with it you know I I do
agree with it being posted on social
media be happy with that for yourself by
yourself
[Laughter]
because why why are we going to create a
community of feeling good being obese
knowing there's so much Health Challenge
there's a lot of people
I'm not talking about the mentality as I
say mentality why are we promoting
obesity knowing there's so much health
challenges behind it that's like you're
saying go have sex with everyone at all
condom but that's what's been promoted
when we should be wearing condoms but
for us but that doesn't get brought on
this discussion and and and and for me I
just feel like I know what you're saying
yeah
listen go have sex with a girl without a
condom you see bro make sure and wear
your robots of course would you you
would tell your boy that right
you don't want to hear your boy yeah
yeah so that's what I'm saying of course
it's protecting everybody else so yeah
but my thing is she's allowed to use
social media how she uses social media
so social media it's up to her it's
freedom of speech it's Freedom of Choice
it's free will if she feels good good
for her yeah but that's you know that's
it that's why I think it's more
important that we shame it
that's what creates mental health wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait and say
and say put the roles away we don't want
to see that put it away go get on the
treadmill lose weight
lose some weight and then come back my
mom used to tell me and everyone's gonna
say yeah no you're right everyone yeah
my mom used to tell me and maybe
everyone's gonna say I was traumatized
that
you have to earn a bikini body and I
believe that I really do and I think you
should earn the right some people don't
want that though it's just up to them if
they don't want to I think I think we
need to please stop talking about
exceptions we want to talk about the
rule I I've said this I I've said to
friends that um might be very overweight
like I think you would have a better
quality of life I think you would enjoy
it more that's as far as I got I would
never shame them for if that's still her
choice I saw her choice I'll do one more
I'll I'll have my overweight friends
um run up 21 flights of stairs with me
I think if you ask someone do you want
to lose weight
90 and 95 98 percent of the answer will
be yes or if they don't and I've been
there I've been there I've been here
I've so when I was a teenager because
I'm very tall when I first had a growth
spent in height I was very very skinny
and I couldn't get really going where it
was extremely hard to me and I hated it
like I've been through that but girls
girls yeah would make comments and stuff
and it made me feel so [__] so like I
feel like there's empathy that comes
from that isn't it isn't that like I did
obviously try and gain weight so I don't
know if that's a difference
basically bullying somebody encouraged
you to be a better person or change your
your ways or whatever to how they think
should be acceptable there are different
people there's the people that could
drive the mindset to get better yeah but
that's that's a different way people as
well
could break down exactly break them down
really bad blah blah blah and you know
you're not accepting this is the
difference is it body shaming to call a
spade a spade to say You're fat you are
fat like you are fat it's not it's not
to be mean but I mean then but it's like
wait wait so it's like how do we fix
problems if we can't acknowledge they
exist this is the problem with the
delusion wait this is the problem with
the delusion of modern women it's like
we can't even acknowledge that there's a
problem how the hell do we fix it if we
can't even say hey the problem is there
yeah I am obese then you can at least
say maybe I should eat less maybe I
should get on the treadmill but it's
like tooth and nail I'm like pulling
teeth here trying to say yeah this is a
problem
but why is it out problem to fix
um why it's not your problem is my
problems
[Laughter]
if we care about someone it is okay to
encourage them but we'll say you I think
we'll have a better quality of life
because this this and this because I
guess it could be from a caring
perspective but not shaming and because
some people do still find them desire we
don't need shame and also what about the
people the minority that can't help it
at least it makes them feel more
comfortable I don't think we needed to
go down to the shame inside like let's
be honest like you would talk to someone
about their obesity yeah the most
respectful exactly
aspect and you say I'm concerned maybe
think of that okay
but that's all you can do it's down to
that individual whether they want to
change their ways obese person as I said
98 of them want to lose weight they do
want to lose weight if you talk them you
ask them a question do you want to lose
it they will say yes and they just don't
know how to so I am not trying to stand
up here and be like oh I am going to
support you being obese yeah I do think
we should shame them off the internet
yeah no I don't think we should be
promoting that to kids so be honest I
think I disagree with kids are kids are
on the internet like I don't think we
should be promoting like fat chicks on
the covers of magazines I don't think we
should be promoting yes Queen that's a
good thing that you're obese like yeah
you do look good on social media there's
kids on social media what messaging are
we pushing and this is why this is why a
lot of women they get they get work done
and this is their exotic example if
you're gonna push The Narrative of
because you need to be perfect then
you're gonna go do certain things to
your body because of idolization
let me let me respond to this okay women
get work done because they're lazy not
necessarily because some some women
lacking in in larger breasts or bigger
bomb and you're going to do that to
please the man or whatever you know what
I'm saying women okay sorry there's two
reasons one they want more attention and
the attention that they got and that God
gave them wasn't enough so they say let
me go get surgery so I can get more
attacks because it's pushed wait wait
wait wait wait wait I need you to I need
you to wait for one second and the
second reason is because they're lazy
and they'd rather get a BBL than go to
the gym I'm serious like they would
rather nutrition nutrition is hard right
nutrition's like the hardest part is
nice 80 is so hot so hard nutrition is
hard working out every day is hard yeah
um getting a surgery is a cheat code
yeah
um to a point now I think that is why
it's a good thing to celebrate
uniqueness and differences otherwise
everyone is pressurized to look the same
a certain way but my brother look I've
done personal training years ago yeah
yeah you're a person training at all can
you grow a bum can you you know
can you exercise and get the same bum as
a bbo a BBL yeah you could shape your
bum you could shape your bum you can't
grow your body you can grow your glutes
a bit talk about it comes with body fat
right okay so my point exactly is
this world is pushing women in flat
front line to look a certain way to
dress a certain way and it makes little
girls on my daughter to look at them and
think I want to be like that if I don't
look like that then I'm a piece of [__]
and I'm not gonna be desired by the
demand that I want or whatever and
that's that's a wrong narrative
the men are asking for this though the
men aren't asking for the botox they're
not asking for the bbls they're not
asking for the lip fillers let me just
do that [__] on their own and that's my
point but that gets glamorized when I
reverse this on like onto yeah you just
said that Society is pushing women to do
these things 100 right then that's the
reason why obesity shouldn't
be on Instagram like that no I hear you
but what I'm saying same thing no but
I'm talking about something different so
I'm talking about the fact that a lot of
these women he just made a really good
point you should acknowledge that was
not really good no I understand but what
she was doing online was self-love it
had nothing to do with her body and how
she looks and she wasn't like oh look at
me I look like this she was just saying
look I feel good or whatever what she
said
that what I got from that video was
self-love and a lot of people don't love
themselves she wanted to say more about
I mean did you understand what I'm
saying it's self-love so if she's saying
okay but again it to me this goes to
delusion if she says I look good and she
clearly doesn't that is narcissism if
you say that I feel good and there's no
way in hell that you can be that big and
feel good
um you're a liar you're a big liar
um narcissistic and delusional you have
a high visceral fat which is going to
cause um
you also have to want to control people
you also normally hurt people it's not
just having self-love and also when you
people are bullied and they are mates
feel [__] about themselves actually that
can lead to narcissism because they have
to be the best all the time and they're
not kind or good to other people so I'm
here to tell them YouTube so I could
help them
this is why we're here to tell them
YouTube that this is why I could help
them also like it might make I said the
sport it might make those minority
people that can't help but feel better
it's kind of like transgender like not
everyone all having different identities
not everyone probably does need to
relate to a different identity but I
guess at least the minority that are
probably born of the wrong time but then
look but that gets pushed more than
obesity though yeah that's a deep one
that's a deep one let's talk about that
then because you want to accept
transgender and stuff but you don't
wanna you know I don't want to accept
that either they scare me a bit Yeah but
but I don't but apparently but
apparently it's accepted apparently we
can't say nothing to them we can't have
an opinion oh I'll say something you
know so let's talk about it please I
want to do a picture I do I do want to
do a panel with um some transgenders and
I want to do a panel with just obese
women so we can talk about these topics
that'll be very interesting
[Applause]
I'd love to be here too yes so so just
pearly things one dm me if you know any
in London I'm serious I want to do a
picture just just transgenders just fat
people we can talk about these issues
some people but it is the minority
they're generally born with the wrong
opposite chromosomes to their genitals
so that's completely understandable but
I think for example I could be called a
tomboy in some aspects when I was
younger I could have some masculine
energy but I would I'm still a female
like but what makes you a female
nowadays you know what oh god let's talk
about it because nowadays here you can
say who you could be whatever you want I
I'm a f i i I'm a starfish
I'm a bird what what are you gonna say
you gotta say you know what I'm saying
so you can't say nothing no more this is
what I'm saying this world is delusional
you can't say nothing you can't have an
opinion about nothing contribute to it
you absolutely contribute to it oh my
gosh during this whole conversation
contributing how
um by bigging up a fat woman and saying
that she looks good when she doesn't I'm
just glorifying how she how she
perceives herself it's a difference
do you genuinely believe she feels good
genuinely I generally feel she feels
good okay that's how she feels I think
35 for 30 seconds if she feels that way
then that's that's how she feels
emotional judge that emotionally you
think you can feel good at it that way I
don't know um
but if she feels happy within herself
good for her
I think she's genuinely happy we don't
know who knows I have no idea who knows
that's what she's presenting us who are
we to Liars come on sorry can I see that
video One More Time
One More Time
what if she has some guy she probably
does have guys going after her like some
guys because he's always a simp
somewhere
turn on the how many views
how many views today
and just be like okay and what are
people saying in the comments
I can't read it this is on Twitter okay
I'd have to see you'd have to go to her
original to see her comments this is
conservative on Twitter
do you ever get dressed and just be like
damn I look good she's very pretty
face can I just say what she she saying
yeah I feel that you know you might have
your days where you don't feel good or
you may you know like you know have a
haircut get a hair done or nails done or
whatever maybe today she felt good like
she got her hair done she got her nails
done she got a nice little dress on she
got her makeup on she feels better than
she usually does so good on her you know
what I'm saying that's all I could say
she looks good you want to know why
that's what she thinks she does she
thinks she looks good to herself okay
and that's good for her but here you see
you can't even you can't even lie I'm
like you she thinks she looks good you
can't even say she looks good so you
know it's yeah but but it goes bad
person it goes by preference so when I
was doing a chart she's not my
preference it doesn't mean that I'm
discreet in how she feels right but I
might not be attracted to white women
Asian women doesn't mean that they're
not beautiful yes it's just my
perception or how I feel 100
of the people in this room said they
wouldn't date obese but that's the
difference so you know that it is not
like the world does not accept her but
yet you continue to lie to her and I
think it's actually meaner to lie than
to tell the truth I think it's meaner to
push this stuff than it is to be honest
with somebody because if you're honest
about a problem we can fix it but you
lie and you lie and you lie and you know
it's a lie and that's the crazy thing
I've asked you guys different questions
in different ways and you know it's not
true
that died from obesity so this is why
I'm
I might get inside
obesity is not I think people need to be
warned about
um it's not uh
it's not something you should be
promoting it's not something you should
be supporting
it
she
thinks that she feels good well she
doesn't
she wants to feel good it's good that
what she's doing for her mental health
why sorry why do you think she's
boosting it on social media
we are commenting on her reaction to how
she felt she looked good that's it
that's it that's it we're not making a
comment on whether we can see that she's
obese whether we like obese people okay
but comment in that she felt good she
expressed that and the level of
confidence is something to be okay when
you saw the video at first did you
notice her weight of course yeah okay
was it was it the first thing you saw of
course
energy if we didn't hear what she said
everything if we didn't hear what she
said yeah okay thank you thank you for
being honest right it was the first
thing you saw of course okay so you
don't think it's it's lying to like to
push this and say that's so great when
you know damn well it's the first thing
you noticed yeah but it's it's like it's
someone's opinion it's like I'm looking
at the video and yeah we know she's
overweight
but I'm not looking and judging her
appearance I'm actually appreciating how
she stands for how she feels so every
question that's it I have a question
you're not judging her appearance um
could you tell if you found her
attractive or unattractive I already
said I don't I don't find oh okay so
that's a lie so you did Judge Her okay
so you did Judge her appearance because
you made a choice in your head
attractive or unattractive and the
weight was the first thing you noticed
so you could say and this is why I'm
saying like I hate lying because it's
like we're programmed to to not say what
we're all thinking because I did say
what we were thinking and at this point
it's like you want us to comment on her
you want us to comment on a way and
we're saying we're not doing that like
it's not a lie like we're saying that we
we write the way that she came in with
that energy and it's not the first her
weight wasn't the first thing that I
noticed because the video was her face
and her neck and her shoulders so why
would that be first thing that I saw it
was the energy that she was giving and
in this day and age
you don't see that many people with
confidence
I see so many women with delusional
confidence that's like so if you walk in
a room with a hundred thousands of it
was of her what what what what advice
would you give to them
damn business no no I'm just saying
advice wise like what if there was to be
like if I was actually put in a position
where I had to tell me something that
that could motivate me tell me something
that could help me with my with my
lifestyle what what advice would you
give to that person I think it's
important that they're warned and
informed about that but surely they are
like everyone knows of course they're
not children they understand what
they're doing to their bodies they're
overweight they surely they understand
that how are they understand if everyone
lies to them through life no genuinely
like if they go through life and this is
the reactions they get how would they
really understand because we're humans
and we're individuals and who cares no
but I'm saying so so I'm saying if
everybody reacts the way you guys
reacted how would they know but if we're
talking about health issues and how they
know what's affecting their bodies
they're grown adults they must
understand regardless of what reactions
they are getting
they know as adults what they're doing
to their bodies it's got nothing to do
who are they now if nobody tells them
why would but how do we know that like
does that how would they know no how
would you know what I think it's through
education like probably how would they
get calories on menus now how would they
get educated if everybody lies
we know there's like obesity pandemics
through the news through education most
women that are surely they would have
gone to school
Works you're seeing that
how would she get better if everything
everybody around guys
and that's the problem is women we go
through life everybody lies to us they
don't tell us like they don't tell us
that geriatric pregnancy starts at 35
you have so much time they don't tell us
that yay you're not worth as much as a
single mother like to the dating Market
they don't tell us that hey when you're
fat you're not valuable like people
don't when people don't aren't as
attracted to you when you're overweight
like they just lie like we go through
society and everybody lies to women
instead of just telling us what it is
you can be valuable outside your weight
though I wouldn't like I find a gym and
my arms smell and I want somebody to
tell me why I'm sweating to be honest
I do think it's a bit ridiculous is like
I don't know it's like the Western world
is just greedy in so many different
senses that that annoys me a little bit
like but then that's like places like
America the portions they do and stuff I
do think it's important that the
government do inform people and they do
make steps because it is do you think
it's like I think it's more on the
people
like to inform each other like I
genuinely think if you really care about
someone you're honest with them
and I I think it's like easier to just
say oh you go girl instead of saying hey
no get on the train do you genuinely
believe that these people do not
understand what they're doing and it is
all based on
reactions from other people
you don't know me you met me today
I'm telling you like I'm just making a
stupid scenario
I'm gonna have sex with this girl
tonight
and I feel really good about myself that
I shouldn't work on them right this girl
has been around
having sex with other men right but I
feel good in myself that I'm confident
enough I mean like anything I'm gonna
have sex without condom would you say go
that's not absolutely that's not the
point that I'm saying I'm saying as so
okay
it's supporting the cause and also we
talk about mentally and physically as
well but you are responsible for your
own actions regardless what anybody says
to you you as a grown man are
responsible for your own actions no
matter who is saying whatever to you
whatever advice you are responsible same
way she's responsible for her while I
agree with that you didn't say to me
that
because you feel good no problem
as long as you feel good point go ahead
and do what you have to do
as long as you feel good go ahead and do
what you have to do because that's not
the point that I was actually
time I was I the question that I asked
is do you actually really think that she
doesn't understand what she's doing to
herself being a responsible an adult and
about a responsible adult would be an
adult understanding the consequences of
her actions do you think she doesn't
understand the harm same way somebody
pointers our reaction to it that's what
I'm trying to get to is our reaction to
it your reaction to me will be what
because we reacted to her
we said that she feels confident she
feels good and that's all you care about
now I want your reaction what would your
reaction be to me
do your thing
it's not my business
knowing that it could be if you feel
good if you feel good about yourself
knowing the risk if you know if you as a
grown man if you know the risks of what
you're getting yourself into it is none
of my business to be telling you what
you should or should not do if it makes
you feel good and you're coming to me
and say I feel really great about this
and if you've seen me so like posting
that kind of thing all over social media
like you wouldn't feel like why is he
posting all over social media is not
good for the world so what so what were
you trying to say yeah so what you're
trying to say is if you're not talking
about this if you're talking about this
woman you know you're trying to say that
she should same team
let me just refresh let me just ask you
a question and kind of what you're
saying yeah maybe I might be wrong but
correct me if I'm right yeah
are you saying that because she's obese
she should hide herself
she should feel oh I should feel every
bit disgusting as much as people think
that that's all I'm not saying no no but
I'm saying because she's out there
glamorizing herself feeling good about
herself but there's people that are
going to be very negative and trying to
pin her down into a position where she
should hide herself lock herself and
never come out and see the day of life
because she's so fat
because I I say like no I'm just saying
you correct me if I'm wrong as well
what she did well she could do it in a
different way where it could become more
positive and how so she's just she could
how she could start her journey that's
gonna help herself get better which is
going to motivate others just like her
to get better based on that you'd don't
know what she's doing you don't know who
she is yeah but there's a lot like her
out there number what I'm saying you're
right but you're missing a point she's
motivating people to love themselves
she's showing you that no matter how you
look how dark you are right you are how
hairless you are how harmless you are
whatever the hell you are all right
no no but let's be real yeah
I feel good forget all that yeah I feel
good yeah I feel good look I could say
that I'm an attractive man I can say
that
you may disagree
you may disagree but I feel that I'm I'm
attractive I feel good why would I let
anybody else tell me different man
forget it man to man yeah let me go back
to this scenario that I brought to her
man to man are you gonna tell me
do what you have to do me personally as
a man I wouldn't
because me as a man I'll look out for
you I'm an avocado because you know the
risk right I know why are we taking that
risk as a positive but I'm looking as a
different form of positivity it's not
her appearance it's her inside it's her
spirit but we're talking body in size no
no but we're looking at it visually
physically you know I'm looking I'm
listening to her her spiritually we are
you know saying to everybody in the
audience that I feel good and that's not
no there's no shame in that sorry that
is the inside as well
it is it physically is in there
in fairy sorry in a very risky condition
so the same way you will tell me bro
I do advise you to do that because you
know it risky it's the same way I'll
advise her not to do the same
yeah but and you wouldn't like me to go
promoting out to others yo all my
brothers listen feel confident in
yourself feel good on yourself go there
have sex with no country I think the
question is like would you guys
encourage your friend
to see that there could be a better
quality of life than because if this is
dualistic we're talking about two
different points because we we
appreciate that she's encouraging
everyone whoever you are to feel good
about yourself and that's important
no we don't want to
but yes we'd also want to encourage
someone in a in a career understand what
I just said I brought you so now you're
in the scene we I said I feel good about
myself I feel very incredible in doing
this you're comparing to do it but
you're comparing an action to somebody
that actually is telling you how they
feel that's completely no I'm just
telling you I feel good about it yeah of
course but you're not you're missing a
point you're gonna do an action I think
you're missing the point actually no no
but he's making he's making bear points
no I don't how can I how respectfully I
don't understand your point reason being
is because you're you're saying you feel
good that's great yeah but you're also
pointing out a very big uh uh uh
curveball here you're saying you want to
have sex with a girl unprotected because
you feel good the intention is not good
but how you feel I can't I can't tell
you how you feel what's wrong because
how you feel but I can tell you that
what you're about to do isn't a good
idea that's my advice I love wages you
get what I'm saying
yeah but she's not saying that she's not
asking to lose weight she's just saying
I feel good no she didn't say good she
said I look good and that's her feeling
good no no and she said but we listen to
what she said but I look good but she
says I look good because she thinks she
looks good that means she feels she
looks good so cool but that also means
that she's good that's also mean that
she gonna continue doing what she's
doing probably probably not who knows
and posting it and bringing awareness to
these scene people who look like her to
be like her yeah but it brings awareness
to show that you can love yourself or
however however you look it doesn't
matter you know that's what I can say
shay said as well she might just feel
good that day I'll be appreciating how
she looks that day she's not saying like
guys I'm obese and I think it's a good
thing and
30 seconds but what do you mean a lot of
them do like that's where we get like
plus size influencers plus size models
like it's becoming common and that's not
good for a society like can we agree
that's not good it's not good to have
more plus size unhealthy people that's
not a good thing in a society
I'm not saying I agree with obesity let
me just say that would you say you
disagree with obesity I I disagree with
obesity because it is a health issue we
all know that we know that I'm not
basing that video upon her obesity I'm
looking at her inside I'm looking at her
heart how she thinks how she thinks that
she feels good that's it would you agree
that her heart is actually in a poor
condition
please I wouldn't know it's about how
she feels please God
most likely they're inside well of
course that's clearly obvious okay
clearly obvious don't you think though
obesity is the the bar of the ABC is a
bit low like there's people that are
classed as obese that aren't that big I
think that actually most people that are
obese don't even know they're obese yeah
like because and I actually think that
like a lot of girls think they're in
shape they're gonna be slim and obese
yeah
no I like I think there's like a lot of
girls like it's weird they'll think
they're normal size and I'm like I'm
looking at you you're overweight like
it's very obvious so what's normal size
to you
um what would you consider that normal
size I'm healthy BMI no but like like
size wise for a woman like obviously you
got plus size and you go yeah I wouldn't
know so I mean you guys sizes run a
little different here but I would say
uh depending on a girl's height like
eight size eight or lower that's quite
small I wouldn't say anything right size
but I I have a friend too you guys you
guys's stuff runs differently the sizes
she she has um
a good big ass but she's really tiny in
the rest of her frame and I think she
told me she was classes obese which is
awesome her lower body yeah well and
yeah not even her legs that much
some some people getting their legs they
bomb their hips people get in different
areas
I mean yeah just yes I just think the
bars are a bit low oh this conversation
is so amazing
very interesting you know what it's
interesting because it's different
opinions and different yeah exactly and
that's all I can say I can't say that
you're wrong and I I I
thank you and that's all I can say you
know what I'm saying and that's your
opinion as well and my opinion is I feel
like you guys are wrong that think the
overweight straight away I feel that you
know how she thought overweight straight
away yeah I'm talking about her I'm
talking about the video the video the
message that she gave in that video was
the fact that she accepts how she looks
and she feels good to buy it that's it
you know what I'm saying
okay I'm gonna read the Super Chat we
also needed a pearl history fact some of
us on some subjects we all agreed with
each other pretty much
who agreed with me though I just want to
know in it on a level
I don't think I agreed with a single
thing you said tonight okay that's fine
that's fine do you agree so you know I
agree though I appreciate it actually
yeah I really appreciate it mentality I
agree with you on the the court stuff
that was what we agreed remember I was
talking about them that's fine yeah
we can agree to disagree
there's different walks of life you
can't judge somebody and we haven't
walked their walk you haven't you can't
judge that that person I think everybody
judges everyone I think I'm the nicest
because I'm honest about it where I
think everyone else is a liar
yeah that's fair enough yeah now
um Lawrence Bullock thank you so much
Lawrence if body positive positive
positivity is good why does it only
apply to women if it were a man on Tick
Tock that it would be met with jokes
what a great Point Lawrence Manny F this
panel would dislike David Goggins taking
Souls Goggins
I think I said his last name wrong and I
don't want to hear about it uh Lawrence
the Obesity discussion illustrates why
women in semps want to be lied to they
don't value the truth they value the
delusion of feeling good
bunk I'm sorry this they're coming for
the couch uh most delusional panel on
the couch yet send the astronaut I think
he meant asteroid but it was a spelling
error
um Dan uh
Lawrence block was traumatizing is
listening to that guy on the couch black
Moses the real reason the reason why men
don't talk about their problems is
because women use them against them
Lawrence there's currency in being a
victim that's why there's an increase in
people going to therapy Jessica my
fiance used to listen to you and I got a
little jealous when he said he agreed
with a lot of what you said and then I
started listening and I became hooked
you got you have helped me become a
better wife and a mother
Jessica that's nice uh subscribe to wife
school
um I recently put out a video where I
learned how to cook for a family of four
in a day Joey British Dave East is
light-skinned tatted or pearly whites
look and looks like he's six foot or
more trying to tell himself he'll move
to girls that have hit the wall would be
um wall the same he would to younger
chicks l-o-l what was that faster I
don't understand that what I can say it
again hold on I'm not always the best
Super Chat reader I get a lot of
complaints for it so let me go back
um David British Dave East
um is a light-skinned is he talking
about you I don't know I don't know yeah
he's a bit above my I don't know who the
Davis is
light-skinned tatted and with pearly
whites and he looks like he's six foot
or more trying to tell himself he'll
move to girls that have hit the wall the
same he would have to younger chicks
because you said you date 50 year olds
or you would
he would be be attracted to him he's
saying yeah he's saying he's a bit of a
Capper we he's a cool guy a bit of a
Capper I like you but a Capper a little
bit maybe uh yeah you I like I like your
cool guy but I just there's been so much
cap tonight
it's just been like an exhausting like
cap cap it's just it's just opinions and
I mean yeah I know you know the Obesity
between male and females the pro the
reason why it's more celebrated than
women is because we do have more
pressure in terms of the way we look
okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna obliterate
that with just one fact who has more
pressure when women find 80 percent of
men unattractive and ugly so who has
higher beauty standards I would argue
the men well we don't we don't object to
find slight men in the same way that
they would I've read I've read
everything Shades of Gray who was the
best seller let me tell you I've read
boys group chats who actually are like
come across gentlemen and man versus
woman
like the way they speak okay
the beauty standards wouldn't you agree
that if women find 80 of men is ugly
that they have harder beauty standards
not necessarily because men obviously
are out there just to just have sex
sometimes so of course they'll drop
their stance doesn't mean they'll drop
them for a girlfriend I don't think they
do I think in most couples the female
is more attractive and I personally
think it it's the it works better like
that because men are more shallow in
terms of look yeah but 80's a lot men
find like half of women as good enough
it's terrible to have sex with but as a
track it starts with sex we agreed with
that right relationships start with sex
nowadays right it comes so so it starts
with sex so yeah so it's harder for men
to get into a relationship so they have
to drop their silence for that bit do
you guys think maybe not even yourselves
but if you see it in French like we have
a weight standard we have a height
standard they can't switch that yeah did
we hear females talking now it is oh he
has to be six foot he has to have a job
yes
none of us picked five five he's screwed
come on we hear these females talking on
Instagram I personally don't agree yeah
I do see that in some of my friends and
I don't agree with it that's one of the
reasons why purposely would be like five
seven and so you think women have higher
standards than men you think higher
higher 100 know what he is though
nowadays it looks to have as a partner
yeah yeah just in general though like
just what they do and like it yeah so
can you think of many friends or
yourself that would go for girls to be
in a relationship though much less
attracted to them and stereotypical
times
or do you think it's more do you see
more females
going out with men okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna give you one out of three men are
either sexless
or that haven't had sex in the past year
or their virgins
so it's like when I was a tree man yeah
one out of three that is that the world
rather than this country or is which I
don't think in England yeah I don't
think I don't think in England
guys guys go walk down the street go to
Costco you think the guy's getting laid
at Tesco yeah but if I think yeah I'm
telling you no yes women find 80 of men
is ugly
ugly men from Tesco getting the
headphone yeah
no if I think about my class at school
or my uni like 100 more than one in
threes yeah yeah because okay your class
at school
wait because your class at school those
men have made it to school there's men
that didn't make it there no one for
three in the UK no but I'm I'm saying
like they're already of a certain
standard to make it into school I
literally mean school school so like in
terms of the UK school is up and before
uni before college so like literally I
think I'm in college okay
when last you guys have been to the club
or Pub or anywhere you see all these
girls are these days
um
I was just saying hmm
if you go like a box pack no you can't
see most of these girls with men who
and say nothing but oh sorry do you
think girls sometimes sleep with people
just feel good about themselves or just
to really 100
well it's like well but the thing is
women I did not I didn't know that women
wait sorry I didn't hear that part like
at the end of the day girls in general
do have lower sex drives than men so
like when they're having casual sex this
is my from my experience a lot of and I
and I speak to a lot of people normally
girls don't feel very good after
normally they haven't done it for them
but the thing is women are sleeping with
a smaller and smaller percentage of men
because women always date across and up
so so
um like literally throughout all of
history throughout all of time like
historically 17 women reproduced for
every one man 8 000 years ago so it's
like like literally historically
monogamy like there's always been more
women to men so it's like now with
social media like women are are sleeping
with a smaller and smaller percentage of
men
like even us we listed as like 20
percent
interesting
yeah wait what were you saying that
means that oh that they have higher
standards in terms of
well because relationships start with
sex nowadays no it is so yeah and so
like women are more selective with who
they have sex with yeah that's true yeah
but that's because
a year or two years
man you must know men that just sleeps
we absolutely should be picky with who
we see yeah 100 I'm not faulting women
for women I'm more pictures I'm even
saying women shouldn't go for like the
Batman is I don't think so I'm not
saying women shouldn't go for the best
guy they can why wouldn't it was the
best person they can I do not think my
men are picky in relationships women are
men are more women are more picky no but
like yes they have sex yeah compared to
who those women are more opinions
choosing a partner a relationship
they're way more picky with that than
who they'll have sex with
uh yeah I mean I don't know yeah yes
I think women are more picky for both
yeah I think women are more picky when
it comes to relationships
yeah I I think so well so normally do
you think these influencers
unattractive it's like they found eighty
percent of men is ugly so that means
they are more picky yeah they are more
picky because even if like even if we're
gonna talk about like the women that are
the the men that women are in
relationships it's still out of the 20
of men they find attractive but that's
that as well we touched back when we
said um so you know some women would get
with someone based on their personality
so it's like again they're being picky
you know what I'm saying like you're not
really looking I don't know I don't know
but I I understand we need to see the
stats of that um percentage-wise in
terms of who men would go and be in a
relationship with to to know for sure
because that's pretty really low as well
yeah do you not know what it is
more I think it's low though
say again women approach men more maybe
you but remember one out of three men
are either virgins or haven't had sex in
the past year they're not going to be
picky yeah exactly exactly
small but the small percentage of men
that are getting laid they're picky but
the rest of them they don't care
that's what I'm saying so it's like
women are pickier because they're all
sleeping with the same guys and so like
a girl that's a six will sleep with a
guy that's a nine and think she's on
their level but she's not she just gets
to sleep with him no it happens yes
because girls can sleep up men men don't
usually sleep up um
but the problem is it makes women
delusional because they think they're on
that level they think they're on the
level of the nine because the Dude will
sleep with her but he just well that's
why they get it wrong when they get the
validation just from sleeping with
someone and then expect to feel better
but then feel worse because someone
sleeping with you same team
it's half and half because you know one
if the man done it good you think that
she's not gonna message him the next day
no I mean yeah she she might do but the
point is is that she shouldn't use
um him having sex with her as a way to
make her feel because it literally means
[__] all a lot of the time men will have
sex people there they do not give a [__]
about so don't have sex with someone to
make you feel better about yourself it
means nothing like feel better about
yourself by respecting yourself I agree
with her I agree with that I 100 agree
with her yeah see I knew we were on this
I support I have a sister so I mean
yeah yeah I have sisters okay I'm gonna
I'm gonna refresh it one more time then
we can give our final thoughts now
um so we're gonna close out the show
because it is getting pretty late
um we're gonna give our final thoughts
um during these final thoughts you can
give your your social media and any
final piece you want to give you know on
a topic please don't make it a monologue
like 30 seconds or less
um yeah starting you go here and then go
around okay
um so thanks for having me on tonight
and my Instagram is Amina house
a-m-i-n-a Dot h-a-u-s and it's been
really good to meet all of you
um and have some open and interesting
conversations so glad we're on the same
team
oh it's me yeah
again like Words man thank you for
having me you know what I mean it's a
good opportunity
um nice to meet everybody and and
getting to know everyone's thoughts and
you know I mean it's it's healthy
conversations
um my Instagram is story that's with uh
I.E instead of a y underscore artists
Emma
yeah copy what everybody's saying it's
been there it's been great to be us it's
definitely been an experience and
hearing out everybody's opinions and
stuff
um yeah it's been it's been a yeah it's
been an experience
uh my Instagram is uh it's so Shay
all right guys so um yeah I really
appreciate you guys having us tonight uh
so my Instagram is is kadeem868 Trinidad
a record
um
yeah man the conversation tonight was
quite a hot man
you know um it's hard but it's good it's
got opinions I mean we all spoke Our
Truth and nice
he's actually on my team
yeah man I really appreciate being here
tonight so thanks you guys have a nice
one thank you guys all for coming I know
it got a bit heated
now to end the show guys a couple
announcements number one
um super chats blessing what I'm saving
for some equipment that blessing wants
so I really do appreciate all the super
chats tonight
um
as for the membership tiers the fourth
tier is the only one that we care about
that is a one-on-one call with me once a
month how do you get a million
subscribers in a year I'll give you all
the cheat codes so follow that one make
it controversial eat
that helps now three I really want to
put together a panel of plus size
influencers in London as well as trans
people well they don't even have to be
influencers people that are Pro Plus
Size movement and people that are pro
the whole trans movement I would like to
give my thoughts to a full panel of them
so if you know any please in DM my
Instagram just pearly things one we
could set up them coming on and go
subscribe to wife school
um that is we're almost to like 30 000
or 20 000 so I don't even know but I
just released an episode and it was
really interesting I had Maggie The
Substitute Teacher on where I cooked for
a family of four for a day I think I'm
gonna borrow a kid for a day in one of
my upcoming episodes so go subscribe to
that thank you guys for watching like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel and I'll talk to you next
time
good
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
[Applause]
I actually agree with you I think they
do do it for the men but it's like
sexual tension it's not relationship
attention so you can kind of do a cheat
code you can go get a BBL get a nice
body and you do get more attention from
them than if you're flat right but
here's the thing though no no but but
listen though it but it goes so deeper
though because I know what you're
talking about and he has a great body
yeah so you got to think about how far
down deep that she is within watching
the Instagram models within watching The
Cosmopolitan magazines
doesn't look good to a man but you think
that men have higher standards for women
not that the men have the higher
standards they have to live up to just
to clarify I think men have highest on
Just for women for women so like the
women have higher beauty standards to me
yes and that's what's making women feel
like they need to comply with these
standards who's picky or men or women
men women are more complacent than them
are more complacent yeah I think they
accept all them and do you think men are
very like if they're they've got a
certain standard and they're more rigid
than women I think men are pickier than
women 100 certainly but they will not
marry they will not settle down with
somebody with a fake or lips the
eyebrows and if they do it ain't gonna
last
vagina feels
right yeah yeah builds right whatever
when I finished it I felt very degraded
I felt very like why did I actually do
that now I know there's girls out there
who do that they don't feel that way
that is perfectly fine you do you you
feel the way you feel but me personally
like like in the future how like when I
have kids and all in the future and if
my kids found out about that they'll
probably get bullied in school there are
people like oh your mom doing this your
mom doing that and your man as well he's
not going to if you don't respect
yourself and you're selling your body
online I can't speak for everyone I can
just speak for myself if you're selling
your body online like that there's not
there's not a high respect for yourself
foreign